Wir wollen jetzt sprechen über La Liga, die Premier League, die Serie A und die Liga. Das tun wir mit Christian Bernhardt, Alexi Menüch, Fabian Pakulat und später noch zugeschaltet Uli Hebel und los geht's! Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt und schön, dass ich hier meine kompetente Runde begrüßen darf. Wir springen gleich rein in die Themen. Keine Zeit zu verlieren. Alexi, wenn du magst, dann leg du doch sehr gerne mal los. Du wirst uns erklären, warum es bei Olympique Marseille schon wieder nicht läuft. Und ich habe gehört, dass de Zerbi schon so wütend verzweifelt war, dass er sein angebliches Papier, was er von Manchester United bekommen hätte, an die Kabinenwand geworfen hat, um den Spielern zu sagen, da hätte ich sein können, ich bin bei euch, jetzt läuft meine Freunde und gewinnt endlich mal. Stimmt das denn, was ich da gehört habe?
Du hast mir schon eine schöne Anekdote weggenommen. Finde ich gut an. Aber ich glaube, es gibt eine andere Version dazu, nämlich dass er nicht jetzt das konkrete Angebot von Manchester United an die Wand gehängt hat, sondern das war vor dem allerersten Training. Er hat ein paar seine Jungs gesagt, schau her, ich habe dieses tolle Angebot gehabt und habe es abgelehnt, weil ich bei einem Verein sein wollte, wo vielleicht kein Europapokal ist auf dem Programm in dieser Saison. Dafür aber ein Verein mit unheimlich viel Leidenschaft, viel mehr Passion drum herum. Der Manchester United trifft ein seit einigen Jahren. Hier in Marseille habe ich das Gefühl, dass etwas möglich ist und deswegen hat er große Hoffnung. Zuletzt gab es natürlich das 04 gegen Paris Saint-Germain, vor allem das 1-3 gegen Orser, den Aufsteiger. Das stand schon jeweils 0-3 zur Pause, sodass die ersten Fans vor der Pause schon nach Hause gingen. Das gab es in Marseille noch nie. Das weiß er auch, der de Zerbi. Man kann nicht die ganze Schule auf ihn lassen, aber er hat trotzdem viele Neuzugänge, die seine Wünsche entsprochen haben. Heute ist Marseille zwar noch dritter, aber sie spielen keine Europavokale. Das heißt, dass sie die ganze Woche Zeit haben, sich aufs Schligaspiel vorzubereiten haben, im Gegensatz zu den Konkurrenten wie Monaco, Lille oder Paris Saint-Germain. Natürlich ist viel zu wenig, was daraus kommt von Marseille. Man fängt die Saison richtig gut an. Man war optimistisch, dass in dieser Saison Torhüter was geht mindestens aufs Podium, aber sogar für PSG ein ernsthafter Konkurrent werden, auch weil Paris Saint-Germain weniger auf Stars setzt und der 45-Tore-Marne weg ist mit Kylian Mbappé. Und de Zerbi hat schon seinen Rücktritt angekündigt nach dem Spiel gegen Ossetia am letzten Samstag. Also wenn ich spüre, dass hier nichts vorwärts geht, dann gehe ich einfach, ich brauche kein Geld. Das ist mir egal. Aber er hat schon auch gedroht. Und das hatten wir schon früher mit St. Pauli, mit Igor Tudor bei Olympique Marseille. Also es sind jedes Jahr die gleichen Sätze, die gleichen Komponenten. Und da fragt man sich schon, was da los ist. Der Verein ist halt von einem US-Amerikaner finanziert mit Frank McCourt, der nach Marseille 1-2 Mal kommt im Jahr maximal. Und dann hast du natürlich den Sportdirektor, den die Bayern-Fans nie vergessen haben, Medi Benatja an der Angel, der schon viele Kontakte nach Italien hat und natürlich viel auch gelernt hat bei Juventus, paar Bayern-Mischen im Punktum Management. Das hat ihn schon immer interessiert. Und er wirkt auch sehr fokussiert und sehr professionell. Aber trotzdem, seit er vor einem Jahr geholt wurde vom Präsident Pablo Longoria, da geht im Verein sportlich nichts vorwärts und das ist schon alarmierend.
Okay, also über de Zerbi müssen wir gleich noch, glaube ich, zwei, drei Worte verlieren, weil da hat ja unter anderem Christian hat da auch seine Eindrücke zu. Aber was wäre denn deine Analyse, wenn wir jetzt eben die Transfers angucken, die da kamen, also Green-Boot-Wall, Connais? Wir haben es auch schon in Teilen angesprochen, Heubier wurde noch ausgeliehen unter anderem von den Spurs. Woran liegt das denn, dass Marseille nicht das erfüllen kann, was man sich vor der Saison vorgenommen hat?
Das Mittelfeld ist auf jeden Fall sehr gut bestückt mit Adria Rabiot und Pierre-Mille Heubier. Das sind zwei echte Coups, die Marseille gelandet hat, ganz klar. Aber du warst kein vernünftiger Rechtsverteidiger, aber das hat der deutsche Rekordmeister auch nicht und gewinnt trotzdem seine Spiele. Also das sollte nicht unbedingt eine Ausrede sein. Im Sturm bist du halt schon dünn besetzt. Marseille holt für 30 Millionen Euro El Iyai. Ron Nans ist ein guter Stürmer, mehr aber nicht. Und er kann den Druck in Marseille einfach nicht standhalten. Er hatte auch vor zwei, drei Jahren gesagt, also wenn es einen Verein gibt, wo ich nicht spielen möchte, ist Olympique Marseille. Und was macht der unter Schreibtort dann ein paar Monate später? Und der wird es auch nicht packen. Also der hat auch den Charakter nicht dafür, die Persönlichkeit. Und hast du seit zehn Jahren, auch wenn Pierre-Emerick umatmeht, in der letzten Saison schon immer wieder getroffen hat, immer wieder die gleiche Baustelle, nämlich eine vernünftige Nummer neun zu holen. Du hast, wie gesagt, Uai jetzt gehabt und da hast du noch. Aber jetzt wirst du davon ausgehen, dass er spätestens im Sommer wieder weg ist. Man hat es versucht mit dem griechischen Mitroglou, mit dem Argentinian, der fiel mir gar nicht mehr ein. Mit B fing es an und E am Ende. Und bei Meyang habe ich schon erwähnt, dass es ging, aber in der Liga hat er auch immer wieder Schwächephasen gehabt. Und wenn du keine vernünftige Nummer neun hast, und das hat Manchester City auch mal gesehen irgendwann, Paris Saint-Germain wird es auch irgendwann mal checken, wenn es der Herr Enrique weniger stur wird. Wenn du deine Ziele erreichen willst, dann brauchst du schon eine vernünftige Nummer neun. Und die hat Marseille einfach nicht, oder schafft es nicht, den zu verpflichten. Und das ist für mich das größte Manko, als vielleicht eine andere Position, wie gesagt, auf der reichste Verteidiger-Position.
Das heißt, es ist eben dann trotz all der Investitionen noch nicht alles super. Und dann lässt der de Zerbi ja aber auch einen Fußball spielen, der sich sehr von vielen anderen Teams unterscheidet. Und gleichzeitig kennen wir de Zerbi schon als jemanden, also dass der früh schon so erregt ist. Ich weiß nicht, Christian, ob dich das überrascht, mit deinem Wissen, was du über de Zerbi hast?
Es überrascht mich insofern nicht, weil Alexi hat es ja vorhin wunderbar beschrieben. Er hat ja schon, dass er da hingegangen ist, er hat das ja auch wahnsinnig emotional aufgeladen. Er hat gemeint, ich bin hierher gekommen wegen dem Villadrom. Das hat er auch immer wieder gesagt. Ich wollte hier Trainer sein, in diesem Stadion. Ich möchte dieses Stadion mitreisen. Und jetzt haben sie diese so schlechte Heimbilanz. Ich glaube, auswärts läuft es ja richtig gut, Alexi, oder? Da haben sie ja fast alles gewonnen, aber eben daheim nicht. Und dementsprechend überrascht mich jetzt nicht, dass er halt sozusagen diesen emotionalen Einstieg auch, den er gewählt hat, quasi jetzt auch emotional auslebt, weil er irgendwie das Gefühl hat, dass er ein bisschen im Stich gelassen wird. Und wenn ich, Alexi, auch eine Frage an dich, wenn ich das richtig sehe, die Spieler haben dann ja alles sofort gesagt, ne, ne, ne, nicht er ist das Problem, wir sind das Problem, wir sind das Problem oder halt wir müssen das umsetzen. Die Frage, die mir sich aufdrängt, klar, jetzt sind es neun Punkte auf PSG, das ist logisch viel, aber war die Anspruchshaltung von Marseille wirklich in der Saison, dass sie sagen, wir müssen Meister werden oder so, weil sie stehen ja trotzdem Punkte gleich auf Rang 2, also zum Rest der Konkurrenz ist ja nicht so wahnsinnig viel passiert.
Also nicht müssen, aber es ist halt der Wunsch, müssen aufs Podium landen, weil wie gesagt, diese Saison kein Europa-Pokal auf dem Spielplan steht und das ist schon herber Verlust, was Image betrifft, sportlich und finanziell und das darf keine zweite Saison in Folge werden, letzte Saison hat man auch schon nur Europa League bestritten und in der Champions League hat man schon lange nicht mehr brilliert und erst einmal muss man sich dafür qualifizieren, also unter den ersten drei, das ist die Priorität. Aber dadurch, dass Monaco und PSG die Champions League bestreiten, dass Paris Saint-Germain uns spielt, der cool auf dem Transfermarkt war und seinen besten Spieler verloren hat, waren genug Argumente, um in der Provence zu glauben, in der Saison geht vielleicht was. Das haben wir auch geglaubt sogar vor dem Klassik gegen PSG vor zweieinhalb Wochen. Also da waren sie sich sicher, da geht was heute Abend. Und wie gesagt, nach einer halben Stunde stand schon 0-3 und eine rote Karte dazu. Und die ersten Fans gingen schon vor der Halbzeit. Und es waren halt Bilder, die schon einige geschockt haben, aber auch gezeigt haben, dass diese Verein einfach in dieses Team noch lange nicht in der Lage ist, um die Meisterschaft zu spielen. Man spricht immer von Projekten hin und her, aber in Marseille hast du auch keinen Insta. Der Druck ist immens durch die Fans, durch diese Passion rund um den Verein. Der größte Druck in Frankreich ist sogar vor PSG. Und insofern können einige Spieler damit schwer umgehen oder gar nicht umgehen. Und deswegen, dass man von Projekten spricht, von zwei-, drei-Jahresprojekten mit de Zerbi, ist einfach nicht zu glauben. Und sollte es am Weihnachten, er hat den 12-Punkte-Rückstand gegeben, auf Paris oder Monaco, dann wird es noch schwerer. Es gibt ein sehr, sehr wichtiges Spiel für Marseille am 1. Dezember zu Hause in Monaco. Du hast es schon erwähnt, Christian, Marseille ist zu sich unheimlich schwer vor heimischer Kulisse. Sollte es gegen Monaco, das gerne auswärts antritt, auch die nächste Pleite geben, dann wird es noch unruhiger. Und man weiß es ja, im Dezember, Januar ist es in Marseille oft sehr, sehr unruhig rund um den Velodrom. Und dann stößt es sich auch nicht aus, dass es schon mal wieder einen Trainerwechsel gibt. Auch weil vielleicht De Zerbi von dich aus sagt, hier komme ich entfahre nicht weiter und vielleicht macht es einen anderen besser.
So schnell kann es gehen. Und ich merke mir das auf jeden Fall. Vor der nächsten Rasenfunk-Saison werde ich euch meinen fiktiven True Crime-Vertrag vorhalten. Ich würde sagen, darauf habe ich verzichtet. Auf dieses True Crime-Format mit Joko Winterscheid produziert von Studio Bowens. Und jetzt redet meine kleinen Freunde. Mal schauen, ob das dann ähnlich erfolgreich ist wie bei de Zerbi. Jetzt habe ich geguckt, Fabian, wie wir die Brücke zum FC Villareal schlagen können. Und ich glaube, bei der Auswärtsstärke, da haben wir tatsächlich eine zwischen Marseille und Villareal. Villareal in der Auswärtstabelle auf Rang 2. Aber auch in der Heimtabelle mit Rang 8 und 11 Punkten aus 6 Spielen gar nicht so schlecht. Und das führt eben insgesamt– und jetzt kommt der entscheidende Punkt– zum 4. Rang in La Liga. Was hat Villareal hingebracht?
Villareal hat natürlich einen sehr guten Trainer mit Marcelino. Den gibt es ja schon ein paar Jährchen länger in Spanien. Er war unter anderem bei Valencia lange aktiv, bei Athletic Bilbao auch erfolgreich. Und bei Villareal war er zuvor auch schon mal. Jetzt ist er im zweiten Jahr, glaube ich. Und er hat– oder was ich dieses Jahr besonders beeindruckend finde bei Villareal– sie haben eine unwahrscheinlich krasse Kaderbreite mit sehr vielen Spielern, vor allen Dingen in der Offensive und vielen Spielern, die sie aus Frankreich geholt haben, aus Marseille, wenn wir die direkte Verbindung holen. Zum Beispiel Pape Geh, oder Geh– ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht. Man hat aber vor allen Dingen in der Offensive viel gemacht und hat dort, glaube ich, so fünf, sechs Stürmer, die alle auf einem ähnlichen Level hoch performen können. Und das funktioniert auch richtig gut. Und er muss im Moment auch verletzungsbedingt viel rotieren. Aber ich denke da zum Beispiel an eine Verpflichtung, wo viele am Anfang noch gelacht haben mit Thierry-Berry oder Berri. Wie gesagt, französisch sind nicht mal die. Ist ja zu 21 Nationalspieler Spaniens geworden. Ist so ein zwei Meter Schlags. Sieht auf dem Fußballplatz nicht immer elegant aus, ist aber schon sehr erfolgreich. Dazu Nicolas Pépé. Den hat man ausgegraben, mal wieder. Der jetzt gerade seinen zweiten oder dritten Frühling erlebt bei Villareal. Wir haben spanische Nationalspieler mit Ayose Perez vorne drin, mit Gerardo Moreno, der im Moment zwar verletzt ist, aber der demnächst wieder da sein wird, mit Alex Baena, der im Moment einer der wohl am stärksten Spanier ist, der mit Sicherheit auch in der Nations League wieder spielen wird, Comisario im Mittelfeld, Jeremy Pino. Jetzt hat sich leider Ilias Akomad ein Kreuzbandriss zugezogen. Am Wochenende hat noch das 1 zu 0 erzielt gegen Alaves. Und dann muss der verletzt ausgewechselt werden. Also die haben unwahrscheinlich viel Potential vorne, sind sehr variabel und spielen einen sehr ansehnlichen, schönen Offensivfußball. Du kannst dich vielleicht erinnern, Max, aber in meiner ersten Ligatur dieses Jahr war dieses Spiel gegen Celta Vigo, das 4 zu 3 ausging, 4 Villareal, was auch 6 zu 7 hätte ausgehen können. Und Villareal hat dieses Spiel gewonnen und hat auch deutlich natürlich die stärkere Mannschaft. Und ich denke, die werden nach den drei Großen im Moment. Es ist für mich zumindest die stabilste Mannschaft in der Liga.
Und sie haben ja tatsächlich nur zwei Niederlagen. Und die waren gegen Barca und gegen Real. Kann man beides auch mal verlieren, auch wenn das gegen Barca dann schon. Da hast du quasi die Kehrseite der offensiven Spielweise gesehen mit dem 1-5.
Das war aber das kann natürlich auch nach hinten losgehen. Vor allen Dingen bei einem Barca, das im Moment bis auf den letzten Spieltag natürlich auch alles getroffen hat, was aufs Tor ging. Wie war das in der Champions League gegen Bayern? Vier Torschüsse, vier Treffer. Also die hatten auch eine ausnahmslos gute Quote und genau, darunter musste auch Villareal leiden. Nein, aber sonst läuft es wirklich sehr gut und wie gesagt, man hat vorne vor allen Dingen, finde ich, ganz, ganz viele Alternativen. Man hat sogar zwei Torhüter, die auf einem ähnlich guten Level sind. Mit Diego Conde in einem Spanier und mit Luis Junior einen aus Brasilien geholt für 12 Millionen Euro, glaube ich, sogar vor der Saison. Der ist jetzt nicht mal Stammtorhüter, aber die wechseln sich ja auch immer ab. Es ist ein Thema allgemein. Wir haben eine extreme große Spielerbelastung und dementsprechend viel Verletzte. Villareal hat dem wahrscheinlich schon so ein bisschen vorgegriffen und hat sein Kader wirklich, ja, ich weiß nicht, wie viel es insgesamt sind, aber es sind deutlich mehr als die normalen 23, 24 Spieler, würde ich sagen. Dazu haben sie eine gute Jugendakademie, wo auch immer Spieler nachkommen. Also die sind sehr gut aufgestellt dieses Jahr.
Also Villareal hat aktuell im Kader 24 Spieler tatsächlich nur, aber wenn es eben so gut läuft, dann entwickelt sich da ja auch manchmal so eine Dynamik.
Die 24 Spieler sind dann aber auch fast halt, also nicht alle auf dem gleichen Level, aber ich würde sagen 20 oder 18 auf einem sehr hohen Level dann. Und dann passt es nämlich auch.
Und deswegen kann er so rotieren. Und was glaubst du, wie nachhaltig kann denn das wirklich sein? Ich meine, aktuell wäre es der Champions League-Platz. Das ist logischerweise nicht das Ziel von Villareal, auch wenn man es natürlich mitnehmen würde. Ich sehe aber so einige Teams wieder da oben drin, die man vielleicht nicht erwartet. Also Osasuna ist aktuell drei Punkte hinter Villareal, fünfter. Dann Mallorca ist relativ gut, wobei da gibt es schon einen kleinen Cut-Off. Also die sind fast schon ein bisschen weit weg. Und ich erinnere mich, aber das hatten wir schon häufiger in La Liga. Wir haben ja selten Vigo als Tabellenvierter, glaube ich, gehabt, nach fast schon der Hinrunde und haben da hier drüber geredet. Was glaubst du, wie groß können die Hoffnungen darauf sein, dass Villareal wirklich durchzieht?
Also ich glaube, bei Villareal ist tatsächlich die Show ziemlich groß, weil sie eben diesen großen und guten Kader haben. Und du hast es angesprochen, Teams wie Osasuna, die Momenten in Lauf haben eigentlich. Da stimmt es von der Qualität nicht so oder ist die Qualität nicht so groß. Und bei denen wird es wahrscheinlich eher nochmal nach unten gehen. Von Mannschaften, die vielleicht noch nachziehen können, denke ich vor allen Dingen an San Sebastian. Aber die haben eine schwierige Saisonphase, eine Doppelbelastung, Verletzte, neue Spieler zu integrieren. Die kommen jetzt gerade wieder so ein bisschen. Weil wir haben mit Athletic Bilbao immer einen Kandidaten, der da reingrätschen kann. Mit Betis Sevilla auch jemanden. Aber ich denke, dass Villareal auch einen besseren Kader hat als Betis und wahrscheinlich auch als Bilbao. Bei San Sebastian sehe ich es relativ auf einer Ebene. Also ich denke, diese drei, vier Mannschaften, die ich gerade erwähnt habe, die werden sich dann um Platz 4 streiten in La Liga. Viel mehr wird ja nicht drin sein. Kennen wir ja leider das Spiel hier. Aber doch, ich denke, dass Villareal da die stabilste Voraussetzung im Moment hat.
Sehr, sehr spannende Tabellenkonstellation und natürlich auch ganz fantastisch, dass ich händeringend nach einer Überleitung von Marseille zu Villareal suche und dabei einfach ausblende, dass Marseille auch für wenige Spiele auch mal Trainer von Olympique war.
Stimmt, Alexi. Auch nicht so erfolgreich, oder?
Nein, der ist aus Angst abgehauen, weil damals gab es eine Art, nicht Revolution, aber Aufstand der Marseille-Fans gegenüber dem Verein, gegenüber den Verantwortlichen und das hat natürlich Marseille noch nie erlebt und er ist einfach geflohen. Im ersten Flieger in Richtung wieder Valencia, Barcelona oder Madrid. Und als Quittung ist er dann wieder ein paar Monate später mit Villareal auf Marseille getroffen, übrigens in der Europa League und Gott sei Dank ausgeschieden.
Ja, sehr schön. Also wir haben eine spannende Tabellenkonstellation in La Liga, aber das ist nichts und zwar gar nichts gegenüber der Tabellenkonstellation in der Serie A. Napoli Platz 1, 26 Punkte. Dann kommen 4. Ich wiederhole 4 Teams, die nur einen Punkt Rückstand haben. Atalanta, Fiorentina, Inter und Lazio. Dann kommt Juve und die haben nur zwei Punkte Abstand. Also, wer rechnen kann, hat gesehen, hier sind sechs Teams innerhalb von drei Punkten insgesamt, die sich da voneinander unterscheiden. Und auf eines davon wollen wir jetzt mal genauer blicken, Christian, und zwar auf die Fiorentina. Was ist denn da so bemerkenswert aktuell an deren Lauf?
Ja, du hast es ja eigentlich im Prinzip schon gesagt. Also, dass Juve, Inter, Atalanta, Napoli und Koda vorne mitmischen, das war zu erwarten. Aber dass die Fiorentina und Lazio da halt auch drin sind, nicht unbedingt. Und deswegen lohnt es sich, ja, die Fiorentina anzuschauen. Fangen wir mal ganz einfach an. Die Fiorentina hat die letzten sechs Liga-Spiele gewonnen. Also, da kann man davon sprechen, dass sie einen Lauf haben. der letzten neun sind sie auch europäisch unterwegs in der Conference League. Und ja, es ist einfach ein wahnsinnig spannendes Konstrukt. Fangen wir mal an, ein bisschen mit dem Trainer. Der Trainer ist es seitens Sommer Raffaele Palladino, der fiel bei uns hier auch schon ein paar Mal im Rasenfunk aufstreben. Der Trainer, der mit Monza in den letzten zwei Jahren richtig gute Arbeit gemacht hat, also auf jeden Fall einer der talentiertesten italienischen Trainers, sage ich mal, der nächsten Generation, der jetzt im Sommer eben den nächsten Schritt gemacht hat, wo ich auch finde, genau richtig, von Monza zu was Größerem, zur Fiorentina, wo er jetzt auch erstmals Europäisch spielt, also die Doppelbelastung kennt. Und das Besondere ist, die Fiorentina ist unter Palladino gar nicht gut gestartet. Nach den ersten vier Spieltagen hatten die nur drei Punkte, haben dreimal unentschieden gespielt, eine Niederlage. Und dann kam ein Switch und ich finde, das macht auch Palladino besonders. Palladino ist bei Monza mit so einem 3-4-2-1 groß geworden. Das hat er durchgespielt, das hat Monza wirklich perfekt etabliert. Er ist ja ein Gasparini-Schüler, Palladino war langs seinem Spieler. Quasi auch gegen den Ball, diese Gasparini-Elemente. Und deswegen ein ganz klares Grede, das er auch mit nach Florenz genommen hat. Aber nach den ersten Spielen, als er gemerkt hat, es so richtig rund läuft es nicht, hat er selbst erzählt, dass er im Gespräch mit der Mannschaft– also viele Spieler sind auch auf ihn zugekommen und gemeint, wollen wir es vielleicht nicht mit der Viererkette probieren. Und er war dann so reif, zu sagen, ja, mache ich, ich nehme das an, was aus der Mannschaft kommt. Und das Besondere dann, das hat er in der Halbzeit im Spiel gegen Lazio gemacht. Also die waren in der ersten Halbzeit gegen Lazio zurück. In der Halbzeit hat er Viererkette umgestellt, die haben das Spiel gewonnen und seitdem läuft es. Das ist jetzt logisch zu einfach ausgedrückt, aber ich finde, das sagt viel, dass Palagino auch eher nicht so ein Ideologe ist, der dann sagt, hey, das ist meine Systematik, ihr müsst euch doch anpassen, sondern er hat verstanden, dass das gut für die Mannschaft ist. Und da müssen wir jetzt auf die Mannschaft schauen, weil halt wahnsinnig viele spannende Typen dabei sind. Da fangen wir im Tor an. David de Gea ist im Tor, da für Rettina, wo wahrscheinlich viele… Ja, ja, ist lustig. Viele haben da vielleicht auch geschmunzelt. Jetzt ist de Gea halt mittlerweile einer der besten Torhüter der letzten Monate, weil ich glaube, viele nicht damit gerechnet haben, dass der zwar ein Jahr lang komplett raus ist, aber vielleicht haben die vergessen, was der die Jahre davor teilweise für ein Torhüter war. Und ich glaube, der hat es wirklich so als Riesenansporn gesehen, nochmal zu zeigen, ich möchte mich noch mal auf dem großen Niveau zeigen. Und das zeigt er. Ohne de Gea wäre die Fiorentina in den Conference League Playoffs schon ausgeschrieben. Da hat er im Elfmeterschießen, glaube ich, drei gehalten. Und jetzt auch in der Liga vor kurzem hat er gegen Milan zwei Elfmeter gehalten. Und das ist viel mehr als nur gehaltener Elfmeter. Also er strahlt einfach eine brutale Ruhe aus. Und das ist besonders. De Gea steht im Prinzip für einen Spielertyp, den die Fiorentinen jetzt viele hatten. Nämlich einige Spieler, die quasi wieder zeigen wollten, hey, mich gibt es noch und mich gibt es auf einem hohen Niveau. Da können wir jetzt die deutsche Karte spielen mit Robin Goossens, der jetzt bei Union Berlin ein schwieriges Jahr hatte. Wie hat er gesagt, Zitat, maximal unglücklich lief das. Jetzt ist er in Florenz und es funktioniert. Yassin Adli, den Alexi auch gut kennt, von Milan, der war da halt auch eher zweite Wahl, kommt da rüber. Es funktioniert, weil er auch Qualität mitbringt. Eduardo Bove, der eigengewächste Roma, dem sie jetzt schon massiv nachtauern, den sie im Sommer haben gehen lassen, der jetzt ein wichtiger Bestandteil ist, der Fiorentiner. Das ist eine lange Liste. Das sind wirklich fünf, sechs Stammspieler, die quasi Cardaldi von Lazio, der ewig bei Lazio war, so ein Lenker, Rhythmusgeber im Mittelfeld, auf den die Lazio verzichten konnte und der jetzt da eine tragende Rolle spielt. Also Palladino hat so eine Schar um sich geschart, quasi von Spielern, die Qualität haben, aber die, die vielleicht zuletzt nicht mehr so zeigen konnten in ihrem Umfeld. Und die hat er jetzt da in dieses Fahrwasser gebracht. Und der, der jetzt am meisten rausleuchtet, den müssen wir logisch ansprechen, ist Mois Ken. Also der Stürmer vordertrin, die Neuen. Auch den kennt Alhex noch, der war ja auch schon in Paris, Riesentalent in Italien, hatte schon mit 16 für Juve debütiert und ist dann so ein bisschen ins Stock hingeleitet. Sicherlich auch, weil er jetzt seinen Beitrag dazu geleistet hat, weil sicherlich nicht immer das professionellste Verhalten, einer, der auch abseits des Rasens immer wieder ein bisschen für Vorrohre gesorgt hat und der in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren bei Juve einfach ein bisschen ins Stock hingeleitet ist. Weniger, würde ich sagen, aus seiner Schuld, sondern ganz einfach geschuldet, da war Vlaović die ganz klare Neun und es gab nur den einen Platz und der war halt der Back-up und hat relativ selten gespielt. Und jetzt kommt er da hin nach Florenz, hat das absolute Vertrauen von Anfang an, Balladino hat ganz klar gemacht, hey, du bist meine Neun, sprich, der spielt jedes Spiel. Und das ist für mich schon die Geschichte, da können wir mal eine eigene Sendung machen. Ich finde, gerade bei Neunern und bei Mittelstürmern ist das halt ein wahnsinniger Faktor. Wenn du weißt, du spielst Woche für Woche, auch wenn du mal ein schlechtes Spiel hast, dann sitzt du nicht gleich über drei Spiele auf der Bank, weil du einen Konkurrenten möglich hast, der dich auf Augenhöhe sozusagen matcht. Und Ken steht jetzt einfach bei acht Ligatoren da, zwölf Saison-Toren schon, hat in der Nationalmannschaft getroffen, ist jetzt fester Bestand der Nationalmannschaft, hat in der Europa League dreimal getroffen. Also da merkst du einfach, der hat es vertraut und der hat logisch gewisses Potenzial, sonst wäre er nicht lange bei Juve gewesen, sonst wäre er nicht bei PSG gewesen. Und deswegen ist auch Ken halt eine wunderbare Geschichte, dass für Arentina dieses Sammelbäckchen, sage ich mal, an Spielern, die zuletzt vielleicht so ein bisschen auf der Suche nach sich selbst waren, da wunderbar zusammengefügt werden. Und das Ganze eben auch aufgrund eines Trainers, der das Systematisch halt sehr angepasst hat. Also er ist weg von diesen 3-4-2-1 hin zu einer Viererkette. Jetzt ist es oft so ein 4-2-3-1, 4-3-3 in die Richtung. Das hat der Mannschaft mehr Stabilität gegeben, auch gegen den Ball. Sie sind defensiv wirklich solide, haben ein sehr gutes vertikales Spiel als eben Adli. Extrem wichtig, weil er ja auch bei mir diese Metamorphose gemacht hat, weg von der Zehn zurück auf die Doppel-Sechs. Und der ist jetzt da gut eingebettet, macht das Spiel oft vertikal. Das liebt Ken, der ist ein athletisch starker Stürmer. Und man muss eben auch, weil wir Gosens schon hatten, die zwei Außenverteidiger, sowohl Gosens als auch Doddo, sind sehr auf dem Papier Spieler, die Offensivstärke haben. Deswegen dachte man am Anfang, ach, das ist ja perfekt mit der Dreierkette, da können die als Schienenspieler richtig anschieben, haben hinten die Absicherung. Aber Palladino hat es halt auch geschafft, dass Doddo und Gosens halt auch in der Viererkette sozusagen defensiv aufmerksam funktionieren und trotzdem ihre Offensivstärken ausspielen. Also es ist wirklich im Moment eine richtig schön anzuschauen, die Mannschaft, die logisch vom Enthusiasmus hier lebt. Und ja, bin gespannt, wie lange sie das so durchziehen. Ein Satz noch eben zu Palladino, weil wir den ja auch schon mal hatten. Ein Zitator zu Marizzo Sarri hat zudem schon vor einem Jahr gesagt, er hat den wahnsinnig im Auge gemeint, also in positiven Szenen, weil er gemeint hat, er verknüpft so Defensive Elemente von Gasperini mit Guardiola-Momenten mit Ball. Also Palladino ist nicht so stringent, was dieses 1 gegen 1 übers ganze Feld betrifft, wie es Gasperini quasi auslebt, sondern hat wirklich gerade mit Ball auch so ein bisschen einen sehr guten Positionsansatz, sehr gutes Positionsspiel. Und allein, wenn Sarri dich mit, sag ich mal, mit Gasperini und Guardiola in Verbindung bringt, dann sagt das schon ein bisschen was aus, weil Sarri ist jetzt nicht unbedingt einer, der irgendwie mit Lob links und rechts um sich wirft. Und nicht falsch verstehen, jetzt geht es nicht darum, aus Palladino einen neuen Guardiola zu machen, überhaupt nicht. Aber das sagt schon, dass einer wie Sarri, der das Business, glaube ich, sehr gut kennt, das schon vor eineinhalb Jahren quasi gesehen hat, dass da ein Trainer ist, der was Besonderes hat. Und der zeigt das jetzt auf der nächsten Stufe. Und ja, da müssen wir nicht drum um reden. Der wird in nicht allzu ferner Zukunft auf einer noch größeren Trainerbank sitzen. Aber erstmal verbreitet er sehr viel Spaß mit der Fiorentina.
Aber wirklich. Jetzt ist natürlich die Tabellenkonstellation kommt, auch daher, dass Napoli gegen Atalanta zu Hause 0-3 verloren hatte und dann 1 zu 1 in Mailand gegen Inter gespielt hat. Deswegen hat sich das alles so zusammengestaucht. Aber nach zwölf Spieltagen, so viele Teams, nämlich die Top 6, innerhalb von drei Punkten zusammen, kannst du dich schon mal an so eine Tabellenkonstellation erinnern und können sich die italienischen Fußball-Gazetten, wie man ja dann immer so schön sagt, könnte die sich überhaupt noch einkriegen vor Begeisterung? Das ist ja fantastisch.
Nee, definitiv. Also es gab es wirklich lange nicht mehr. Man muss sogar dazu sagen, wenn Milan am vergangenen Wochenende nicht noch ganz dumm spät das 3-3 kassiert hätte auf Caliari, die haben ja noch ein Nachholspiel, dann könnten die auf 23 Punkte kommen. Dann wären die auch noch da mittendrin. Also ja, es ist wirklich großartig. Und du hast es schon angesprochen, das Besondere ist– oder was heißt das Besondere? Vielleicht auch die Grundlage, dass so eine spannende Konstellation entsteht. Die haben sich alle gegenseitig Punkte weggenommen. Also du hast es gerade angesprochen. Napoli hat gerade zum ersten Mal verloren seit Monaten gegen Atalanta. Atalanta hat gegen Inter verloren. Inter hat gegen Milan verloren. Milan hat aber dafür Inter geschlagen. Es ist wahnsinnig ausgeglichen. Es gibt wirklich viele Spitzenspiele. Ich würde sagen, bei der Fiorentina, bei Lazio muss man schauen, wie lange das anhält. Ob sie ganz oben dabei sein können. Aber bei Atalanta, Juve, Napoli, Inter– und ich würde auch Milan nicht komplett rausnehmen, bin ich mir sicher. Ich glaube, dieses Jahr gibt es eine ganz andere Entscheidung als die letzten zwei Jahre, wo wir einmal Inter und einmal Napoli einfach komplett davongerauscht sind. Ich glaube, dieses Jahr ist wirklich vieles da, um einen wirklich langen, sehr spannenden Meisterkampf zu haben.
Hoffentlich haben wir es jetzt hiermit nicht gejinkst. Stimmt. Aber wir werden es ja sehen in der Ligatur. Das waren quasi unsere großen Themen. Jetzt wollen wir noch ein bisschen den Scheinwerfer schneller drehen und durch die Ligen springen und durchaus auch mal Spieler nochmal in den Fokus rücken. Alexi, du darfst mal anfangen. Wir haben mit David Jerea einen der besten Torhüter der Serie A jetzt gerade gehört und dass er immer noch da ist. Da haben wir in der Ligue 1 aber auch jemanden, der gerade sehr gut performt.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich wieder Schwierigkeiten bereiten wir für die Deutschen mit seinem Nachnamen, Lucas Chevalier. Französisch, da geht es nicht mehr. Was für eine Entwicklung in den letzten Monaten. Das hat sich natürlich gezeigt jetzt in der Champions League. Ligue 1 hat ja immerhin zwei Madrid-Clubs oder die zwei großen Madrid-Clubs bezwungen innerhalb von zwei Wochen. Real und bei Critico gewonnen. Dann gegen Juventus einen guten Unentschieden geholt. Und da hat Chevalier wieder sehr viele Paraden gezeigt. Der ist einfach ein kompletter moderner Torwart. Der ist stark auf der Linie, stark beim Rauskommen. Nur einer hat ihn bisher ignoriert, das Idol von Christian de Medici des Champs. Fragt euch jeder, warum.
Ich muss jetzt kurz das Audi anmachen.
Es hat ihn endlich mal geholt als Nummer 3, weil der Ersatzverwalt von West Ham, Alphonse Areola, hat sich verletzt, so dass Chevalier reinrutschen durfte. Aber für viele Experten gilt er schon als Nummer 2. Er ist eigentlich schon besser und kompletter, konstanter als Brice Samba von Lyon. Ich bin der Meinung, er ist noch besser als Mike Mignon. Weil er noch kompletter ist. Mignon sieht so ab und zu– also, das ist meine Meinung oder meine Beobachtungen von ihm– dass er nicht immer auf den Punkt konzentriert ist, bei manchen Spielen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das auch bei Milan der Fall ist, aber er könnte noch konstanter werden, ein Tick konstanter. Und das fällt ihm. Natürlich hat er auch vielleicht durch seine Probleme mit der nationalen Mannschaft dadurch auch ein bisschen irritiert geworden, sich zu fokussieren. Aber zurück zu Chevalier. Er ist für mich der Torwart der Zukunft. Er ist Mitte 20. Und wenn ich all diese Namen sehe, was da an der Säbener Straße läuft für die neue Nachfolge, und der taucht nicht auf, das wundert mich schon. Auf jeden Fall soll Bayern Möbel holen und nicht Chevalier. Dann wird es in Zukunft andere Meister geben in Deutschland.
Sehr gut. Aber komm, Alex, wir haben uns doch schon mal über das Scouting des FC Bayern unterhalten. Das war jetzt nicht on air, aber ich weiß, dich wundert es eigentlich nicht wirklich, dass dieser Name nicht fällt. Aber immerhin, wir haben ihn jetzt genannt. Lyka Chevalier, Torhüter von Lille. Und dann blicken wir auch mal noch mal in La Liga. Da schauen wir jetzt aber auf die Trainerposition, Fabian.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, in letzter Zeit komme ich immer nur auf Trainer und die Spieler überzeugt mich keiner so sehr, wobei es natürlich viele gute Spieler in Spanien gibt. Nein, aber ich habe mir dieses Mal den Trainer von Osasuna rausgesucht, Vicente Moreno, weil du schon vorher angesprochen hast, die sind im Moment überraschend tabell und fünfter. Sie spielen einen richtig starken Fußball. Übrigens auch mit Brian Saragossa vom FC Bayern, der richtig gut spielt bei Osasuna. Viele Tore schon geschossen hat und auch viele Vorbereitungen, viele Tore vorbereitet hat. Der hat der Schritt zurück, dem hat er sehr gut getan, weil er jetzt einfach A-Stammspieler ist und B-Befreit aufspielen kann. Also er darf auch ins Dribbling gehen, er darf auch vorne ausprobieren. Und die Geschichte von Vicente Moreno ist ein bisschen heftig, weil eigentlich war er schon weg vom Fenster. Er hat in der Saison, glaube ich, 2020, Espanyol Barcelona übernommen, ist mit denen aufgestiegen in die 1. Liga, ist dann aber relativ schnell ab nach Saudi-Arabien zum Geldkassieren, zu einem Team, das heißt El Shavabah, das ist jetzt auch, glaube ich, nicht das krasseste Team in Saudi-Arabien, aber gut, die haben wahrscheinlich gut gezahlt, ist dann zurück in die Liga gekommen zu Almeria. Da gibt es die Parallelien, weil Almeria ja diesen Saudi-Scheich hat als Eigentümer. Und ich schätze mal, da wurde da irgendwie gemauschelt und getrickst. Bei Almeria wurde er dann innerhalb von drei, vier Monaten gleich entlassen. Die sind ja letztes Jahr abgestiegen aus der 1. Liga, also da war er am Anfang der Saison noch Trainer. Das hat nicht funktioniert und dann hatte man eigentlich schon bei ihm so das Gefühl, okay, auf seinem Zenit ist er nach Saudi-Arabien, jetzt versucht es wieder, klappt nicht mehr, das Ding ist gelaufen. Aber dann hat ihm Ossasuna am Anfang der Saison immer eine Chance gegeben und er nutzte wirklich bravourös, wie gesagt, er war im fünften, wir haben es angesprochen. Und dann gibt es noch nebenmenschlich eine schöne Geste gerade. Wir haben ja in Spanien gerade aufgrund der Unwetterkatastrophe im Moment, sind die schwarzen Flagen gehisst, sage ich jetzt mal. Und er hat tatsächlich auch mit einem Spieler sich freigenommen vom Verein und ist in seine Heimat nach Valencia gefahren und hat dort mitgeholfen, um aufzuräumen und versucht, den Leuten dort vor Ort zu helfen. Auch ein weiterer Spieler von Ossasuna, Ruben Garcia, der kommt auch aus der Region Valencia. Es gab mehrere Spieler, die nach Valencia gereist sind und das Training schwänzen durften und dort helfen durften. Und es war einfach eine schöne Geste auch, dass man den Spielern und den Trainern diese Freigabe erteilt hat, um das machen zu können. Die Liga hat es ja nicht geschafft. Die Liga hat alle zu allen Mannschaften gesagt, ihr müsst spielen, also vorletzten Spieltag in dem Fall. Kurz nach dieser Katastrophe, wo eigentlich das ganze Land noch unter Schock stand, bis auf die Teams aus Valencia musste wirklich jeder spielen. Und da hat jeder eigentlich einstimmig gemeint, dass das eigentlich eine katastrophale Entscheidung von der Liga war. Und umso schöner dann eben, dass die Vereine unter sich das ein bisschen besser managen. Und Vicente Moreno, wie gesagt, er lebt sportlich einen zweiten Frühling sozusagen und ist auch menschlich im Moment. Ja, zumindest auf einem ganz guten Podest. Und ich hoffe, dass es weitergeht mit Osasuna. So positiv, denn es ist echt ein toller Club. Und schauen wir mal, wie es dort weitergehen wird.
Da haben wir jemanden, der seinen zweiten Frühling erlebt hat. Jetzt sprechen wir über jemanden, da würde ich sagen, ist wahrscheinlich der erste Frühling, oder? Ademola Lukmen von Bergamo. Bei dem wollen wir jetzt sprechen, Christian. Und der ist ja Teil der Erklärung oder der Antwort auf die Frage, warum Atalanta gerade so gut ist.
Genau. Ich habe ihn stellvertretend genommen, aber man kann ihn auch ganz einfach persönlich nehmen. Ja, herausragend hat vor kurzem das Spitzenspiel, das ist schon angedeutet, in Neapel, auswärts bei Neapel, die zwei Monate umgeschlagen waren. Beim 3-0 macht es erst 1-0, macht es 2-0. Der VfB Stuttgart hat ihn zu spüren bekommen, hat ganz Atalanta zu spüren bekommen, würde ich sagen, in der Champions League. Er macht auch eher das 1-0. Zwei Ligaspieler davor hat er ein Vier-Score-Punktspiel mit zwei Toren, zwei Assists. Also, Lukman ist ein, wir hatten, ich glaube, mein letzter MVP war Retegi, weil der einfach alles vorne wegknippt. Jetzt ist es Lukman. Also, es sind Individuen logischerweise bei Atalanta, aber es ist halt auch dieses Kollektiv, das Gasperini da halt wieder mal auf die Straße bekommen hat. Und Lukman gibt dem Ganzen halt schon so eine spezielle Note. Also, das ist, ich meine, ihr habt ihn wahrscheinlich die meisten vor Augen. Dieses extrem Wendige auf engem Raum, halt diese Dribbelstärke, aber halt auch mit einer gewissen Zielstrebigkeit. Also, das ist halt nicht nur so da, um einen coolen Move zu machen, sondern der steht jetzt halt in der Serie A. Wir sind jetzt Mitte November, steht da bei 6 Toren und 4 Assists. Also, der steht halt bei 10 Skorepunkten. Allein in der Liga, eben in der Champions League, kann man noch ein paar oben drauf. Also, Luqman plus Retegui plus eben de Quetellare, die sind halt sozusagen die offensive Speerspitze von Atalanta. Aber sie funktionieren halt auch so, weil sie halt dieses ganze Gasparini-Konstrukt hinter sich haben. Und ja, ich habe ihn jetzt gewählt, weil Atalanta auch wieder die letzten 6 Ligaspiele gewonnen hat, auch international 8 von 9 der Letzten gewonnen. Und das eine Unentschieden war nur das Celtic-Heimspiel, das 0-0 ausgeht, wo man sich denkt, ah, ja, und da hatten sie wirklich 6 Top-Chancen, 6 Groß-Chancen. Die haben sie halt nicht genutzt, das kann halt auch mal vorkommen. Aber es war jetzt auch kein schlechtes Spiel, sondern da hat halt die Chancenverwertung nicht gepasst. Also Atalanta ist im Moment wieder in so einer Phase, wo die echt für jeden in Europa unfassbar schwer zu bespielen sind. Und Lukman gibt ihnen so diese gewisse Unvorhersehbarkeit, diese spezielle, oft schwer zu greifende, technisch unglaublich starke Moment.
Also Lukman gerade richtig, richtig gut in Form. In der Ligue 1, Alexi, haben wir jemanden alten Bekannten. So alt ist er nicht, aber bekannt ist er aus der Bundesliga, der nicht so wirklich in Form ist. Was ist da los bei Youssoufa Moukoko?
Erst einmal muss man sich noch kurz zurück erinnern, dass er kurz vor einem Wechsel zu anderen französischen Vereinen entstand im Sommer, nämlich zur Olympique Marseille und Lille. Und da hat sich kurzfristig der Transfer zerschlagen, weil es wieder dubiose Zahlen gab und Verhandlungen zwischen Marseille und dem Moukoko-Klang, sodass man sich in Marseille distanziert hat am Ende, weil man einfach die Zahlen des Moukoko-Klangs nicht erfüllen konnte. Mit Nitsa hat es geklaut, aber per Leih. Der ist nur ausgeliehen von Borussia Dortmund, Kaufoption 18 Millionen Euro. Aber dass die Chancen stehen, dass die Kaufoption gezogen wird, ist so groß wie 60 München demnächst in der 2. Liga aufsteigt, also bei Null. Moukoko in Nizza ist ganz einfach. Zwei Tore erzielt und das war beim selben Spiel. Das war beim Kantasieg 8-0 gegen Saint-Etienne. Das war im September. Und seitdem wurden seine Leistungen immer schlechter, so dass er mittlerweile nur noch auf der Bande sitzt und auch noch kaum eingewechselt wird. Zuletzt gegen Monaco beim Cote d'Azur-Durby und auch gegen Lille, also zwei wichtige Meisterschaftsspielen, saß er 90 Minuten auf der Bank. Das Problem ist natürlich, rein sportlich, dass es schwer ist, diese neue Spielweise anzupassen, weil sie ganz anders ist als bei Borussia Dortmund. Also weniger Pressing, weniger Intensiv, mehr Ballbesitz, Fußball bei Nizza mit dem neuen Trainer Franck Eze. Und auch ein Sprachproblem. Nur Dante kann ihnen helfen, unterstützen im täglichen Leben. Aber das war es schon. Koko kann zwar Englisch, aber den meisten neuen Mitspielern nicht. Das ist schon ein Problem für die Anpassung, für die Eingewöhnung. So dass heute schon viele davon ausgehen, dass er spätestens im Sommer gehen wird. Oder dass es in den Vereinen sportlich nicht passt. Das haben die Verantwortlichen von Nizza leider auch schon festgestellt.
Bräuchte 1000 Dantes, dann könnte er sich besser verständigen. Bei Nizza, ja, Mokuko. Eine Spielminute in den letzten drei Spielen läuft wirklich gar nicht gut. So ist der Stand bei Jusufa Mokuko. Dann schauen wir nochmal nach Spanien. Fabian, wen hast du uns noch mitgebracht? Du bist Trainer-lastig heute, aber aus gutem Grund.
Ich bin extrem Trainer-lastig heute, ja. Ich habe euch einen Trainer mitgebracht, und zwar vom Aufsteiger Leganes. Der heißt Borja Chimines, ist ein relativ junger Trainer, ist Aufstiegstrainer und hat mit Leganes letztes Jahr in der zweiten Liga einen Wahnsinns-Saison gespielt, ist dort als Tabellenerster schon, weiß ich nicht, einige Spieltage vor Saisonende, stand da als Aufsteiger fest. Und macht jetzt, glaube ich, mit dem geringsten Budget der spanischen Liga oder zumindest in den unteren Top 3 zu finden, einen richtig guten Job. Leganes hat am Wochenende Sevilla geschlagen mit 1 zu 0. Sevilla kommt weiterhin übrigens nicht aus dem Puschen. Und diese Borja Chimines schafft es tatsächlich mit Spielern, die einen Marktwert von 1 bis 2 Millionen zum Großteil nicht übersteigen, dort wirklich ordentliche Leistungen zu bringen. Sie haben hier am Anfang der Saison mit Sebastian Aller die große Überraschung sozusagen geholt. Der hat auch am Anfang gespielt, glaube ich sogar das ein oder andere Tor gemacht. Jetzt war er verletzt. Ich glaube, er kommt jetzt dann wieder nach der Länderspielpause zum Einsatz. Aber der ist so mit Abstand der wertvollere Spieler im Vergleich zu allen anderen. Dementsprechend wollte ich dem 39er Trainer einfach mal diesen Ansatz an Hero geben, weil ich denke, er macht auf sehr gute Arbeit in einem kleinen Dorfverein sozusagen. Leganes ist ja eine Vorstadt von Madrid. Da ist kein großes Stadion, da ist kein großes Fanumfeld. Also da ist es schwierig zu arbeiten, denke ich mir. Aber er macht es wirklich sehr gut. Und schauen wir mal, ob er dieses Jahr die Klasse erhalten kann mit Leganes.
Steht er denn für irgendwas als Trainer oder ist schon seine Hauptkompetenz, dass er eben aus geringen Mitteln, in Anführungszeichen, was eben den finanziellen Einsatz für Spieler angeht, dann viel formen kann?
Letztes Jahr waren sie schon sehr dominant in der 2. Liga. Jetzt in der 1. Liga versuchen sie noch, sich so ein bisschen anzupassen. Am Anfang war es wirklich sehr offensiv, aber da haben sie relativ viele Tore geschossen, aber die Spiele dann trotzdem verloren. Und jetzt haben sie ein bisschen umgedacht. Jetzt reicht auch mal ein dreckiges 1 zu 0 gegen Sevilla. Und ich glaube, das zeigt auch, dass er anpassungsfähig ist. Und was er auch sein muss natürlich jetzt nach diesem Qualitätssprung mit dem Aufstieg. Und natürlich spielt Ligand nicht mehr so offensiv und so druckvoll, wie vielleicht noch in der 2. Liga. Aber wie gesagt, sie grooven sich da ganz gut ein. Sie spielen in der 1. Liga und nehmen die Herausforderungen an. Und ich denke mal, es geht vor allen Dingen um schnelles Umschaltspiel. Da haben sie vorne schon ein paar gute Männer mit Juan Cruz. Vor allen Dingen, der spielt eine richtig starke Saison. Der von Betty Sevilla kam dort, der zu wenig Chancen bekommen hat, der übrigens aus Malaga stammt, der auch mal beim FC Malaga gespielt hat. Und der im Moment richtig vorm Stalk ist. Und schauen wir mal, wie es weitergeht bei Liganes.
Also ich stelle den internen Ligatour-Bingo-Counter auf drei. Wir hatten schon zwei Münchenseitenhiebe von Alexi. Wir hatten jetzt einen Maler-Vergleich. Wenn jetzt hier gleich noch gewisse italienische Trainer als verstanden werden von Christian, dann haben wir ein volles Bingo. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob er das hinbekommt, wenn er jetzt über Alessandro Bongiorno von Neapel sprechen will. Christian, deine Bühne.
Genau. Also ich würde mir erlauben, die Kategorie leicht anzupassen, weg von Ansang, weil Ansang ist Bongiorno nicht hinzu. Man kann ihn nicht genug besingen. Und zwar, ja, Bongiorno ist ein Verteidiger von Napoli, in das ist Vorderzession ja von Torino gekommen, hat 35 Millionen gekostet, war eines der größten Investments, aber ist halt jeden Euro wert. Jetzt im vergangenen Wochenende gab es das Spitzenspiel in San Siro, gegen Inter, 1-1, Napoli ungeschlagen geblieben. Und was Bongiorno da speziell mit Toram, also mit Toram und mit Martinez, mit Lautaro gemacht hat, das war schon herausragend, hat keinen einzigen Zweikampf verloren, ohne Foul ausgekommen, 90 Minuten gegen Toram und Lautaro. Das sind jetzt nur so einzelne Statistiken, aber ich habe eine Szene vor Augen, ich hatte das Glück, durfte das Spiel kommentieren, da gab es ein Laufduell mit Toram und jeder weiß, glaube ich, dass das die unangenehmste Situation ist für einen Verteidiger, wenn Toram etwas Platz hat, mit Ball am Fuß quasi in den Raum reingehen kann. Ja, und Bongiorno ist das Tempo mitgegangen und hat die ganze Situation ohne Foul geklärt. Also am Ende war er am Ball. Und das ist so eine Szene, die wirklich zeigt. Also Bongiorno ist für mich im Moment, Bremer hat sich ja das Kreuzband gerissen, fällt die ganze Zone aus, ist im Moment der stärkste Innenverteidiger der Serie A. Und da hat wirklich Napoli in Riesenkuh gelandet, auch ganz interessant. Inter war im Sommer auch noch mal dran, hat sich probiert, da reinzumischen in den Transfer, aber konnte, war ganz klare Ansage, ich brauche Bongiorno, ich brauche Bongiorno. Und ja, zeigt sich jetzt, warum. Bongiorno hat am ersten Spieltag gefehlt, da hat Napoli dieses 2 zu 3 in Verona kassiert. Seitdem haben sie jetzt, bis auf dieses Atalanta-Spiel, nie mehr verloren. Sie haben bei Milan auswärts zu Null gespielt, sie haben bei Juve auswärts zu Null gespielt. Bongiorno hat immer dafür gesorgt, Morata rausgenommen, Pjulisic rausgenommen, Vlaović rausgenommen. Von dem werden wir die nächsten Jahre auch noch viel mehr hören, denn es ist logisch auch Bestandteil der Nationalmannschaft. Das ist jetzt so die eine grosse Aufgabe, die Spalletti da hat. Die Italiener sind in dem Punkt sehr gut aufgestellt, mit Bongiorno, mit Bastone, mit Calafiori. Das einzige Problem, unter Anführungszeichen, sind alles drei Linksfüsse. Normalerweise tust du dich oft schwer, solche zu finden. Die Italiener haben jetzt drei auf einen Haufen. Mal schauen, ob Spalletti da eine Mischung findet. Aber Bongiorno, 1a Verteidiger, der jetzt schon ganz, ganz weit vorne ist. Und ich glaube, der in den nächsten Jahren dann noch mal, gerade unter Konter, auch noch mal Schritte machen wird.
Okay, und ich stelle fest, das Bingo ist es nicht gefallen. Du hast den Namen vermieden. Mal sehen. Eine Chance wirst du noch haben. Vorher schauen wir aber noch mal ein letztes Mal auf die Ligue 1 und tatsächlich auf die Liga als solches. Alexi, über wen möchtest du noch sprechen? Was ist deine Geschichte dieser Woche?
Über einen Mann, über den man ein Buch schreiben könnte. Nicht unbedingt positiv. Über den hätte man auch schon in den letzten Wochen sprechen können, weil er war der Hauptverantwortliche dafür für die neuen TV-Rechte in Frankreich. Das ist der Liga-Präsident Wansana Brün, der eine großartige Karriere hinter sich hat. Da bin ich ernst, objektiv. Er war ja TV-Produzent, dann war er auch sogar Präsident von Big Marseille. Irgendwann ist er dann zum Liga-Präsident gewählt worden, nämlich vor fünf Jahren. Die große Herausforderung für ihn war die neuen TV-Rechte, die ja vor ein paar Wochen vergeben wurden. Die sollten im Oktober vergeben werden. Für die Periode 24, 29, also fünf Jahre. Und die sind vergeben worden zehn Tage vor dem Liga-Stadt. Zehn Tage vor dem Liga-Stadt, sodass man keinen neuen Sender hatte. Man wusste nicht, wo die Liga zu sehen sein wird. Die Liga wollte sogar sein eigenes TV-Kanal produzieren. Und das wird auch wahrscheinlich die Lösung sein in der Zukunft sein. Aber er hat halt die Gabel gehabt, dass alle 18 Präsidenten der Liga hinter ihm sind, obwohl er dafür sorgt, dass es der Liga schlecht geht. Finanziell ist man fast bangraut. Er wollte eine Milliarde für die neunte Vorrichtung, hat aber insgesamt knapp 400 Millionen gekriegt für die nächsten fünf Jahre. Er hat auch wahnsinnig ein dreifaches zu hohes Gehalt, weil die Liga ja eine Partnerschaft lebenslang mit CWC– habt ihr auch in Deutschland, kennt ihr auch schon in Deutschland mittlerweile– unterschrieben haben, nur mit der Bedingung, dass man 13 Prozent der Umsätze dann jedes Jahr an CWC überweist. Enorm viel Geld, sodass heute die meisten Ligue 1-Vereine– vielleicht nicht von der Pleite herstellen– aber jeden Cent zahlen müssen. Deswegen ist es umso imponierender, dass die Ligue 1-Vereine außer PSG natürlich in den Champions League performen. Du hast Breistag als Dritter, Monaco als Vierter. Und Lille ist auch gut platziert. Nur PSG könnte ausscheiden– ohne Playoffs übrigens– Ende Januar in Stuttgart ausgerechnet. Das ist schon verrückt, was da in Frankreich gerade im K1-Fußball abgeht. Du hast auch noch den größten Star verloren. Er wurde auch nicht ersetzt vom Namen her. Du hast keine absoluten Top-Stars mehr in Frankreich gerade in der Liga. Außer Mugurgo natürlich. Und dieser Vincent Labrun, obwohl er schlecht verhandelt hat, obwohl er diese Rette für nur knapp 400 Millionen Euro verkaufen konnte, alle letzten Minuten wurde er ein paar Wochen später wieder gewählt. Und zwar über 90 Prozent. Obwohl er auch ein guter Konkurrent hatte mit Cyril Linet, ehemaliger Kanaplüss-Chef, L'Equipe-Chef, sehr besonderer Mensch, nicht auf Skandale wie Labrun gezählt. Und Labrun ist, wie gesagt, weil er alle Präsidenten hinter sich hat, weil er die über die Jahre immer wieder überzeugen konnte, ist er wieder locker gewählt worden. Und noch zum Schluss, er hat– und das war in seinem Vertrag unterschrieben von allen Präsidenten– im Durchschnitt 17.000 Euro monatlich nur an Reisekosten ausgegeben. Und er war nicht weit weg. Also er war nie in New York oder Sydney, sondern er war immer schon in Frankreich in der Nähe. Aber er hat sich die schönsten Hotels, Flieger und Restaurants ausgesucht, sodass er schon als Skandaltyp gilt in Frankreich. Und das sorgt schon dafür, dass es im Großen und Ganzen der Liga von der Konkurrenzwierigkeit viel besser werden könnte, ohne ihn.
Es wird ja auch auf Verdacht wegen Veruntreuung von öffentlichen Geldern gerade gegen ihn ermittelt.
Absolut.
Und ich denke, man kann es so deutlich sagen, das stinkt alles zum Himmel. Also dieser CWC-Deal ist das schlechteste Deal der Geschichte. Alle anderen Ligen haben diesen Anteilsverkauf auf 20 Jahre beschränkt. Die Liga hat es unbefristet aufgesetzt. Gleichzeitig war ja damals schon bekannt, dass ein großer Teil von Geld auch direkt an La Brune und noch einige andere, die für diese Entscheidung zuständig waren, geflossen ist. Er hat seinen Gehalt höher gesetzt. Plus eben dann diese nicht zu erklärende, also rein faktisch nicht zu erklärende Rückendeckung von sehr vielen anderen Präsidenten. Wenn wir einfach mal in die Geschichte der Sportverbände gucken, was könnte da passiert sein, dass man so unwidersprochen immer gewählt wird? Ich weiß es nicht. Überlegt es selbst, liebe Leute, aber ich überlege schon ganz lange, dass man da eigentlich mal ein Tribügenspräch dazu machen müsste, weil die fahren sich gerade an die Wand und er ist das Gesicht davon. Meiner Meinung nach. Du hast es ja auch gerade schon sportlich angetan.
Das sind wir uns zu 1000 Prozent einig.
Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn. Gut, schauen wir nochmal nach Spanien. Ich glaube, da wird es jetzt nicht ganz so anrüchig, Fabian. Was möchtest du uns da noch als Geschichte der Woche erklären?
Ja, es wird nicht anrüchig, aber es gibt in Spanien eine sehr unschöne große Verletzungswelle im Moment. Wir hatten am letzten Spieltag drei Kreuzbandrisse an einem Spieltag zu verzeichnen. Militao von Real Madrid, jetzt glaube ich auch schon zum zweiten Mal in zwei Jahren, Frank Gehser von Leganes und Ilias Akomatsch von Villareal, den ich vorher schon angesprochen hatte. Dazu viele kleinere Verletzungen, oder was heißt, kleinere mittlere muskuläre Verletzungen. Lamín Jamal ist jetzt wieder mal wieder verletzt. Der Anzufahrt, der hat sich verletzt. Lewandowski hat sich verletzt. Wir kennen diese kleineren Verletzungen auch aus den anderen Ligen, die passieren oft, aber in Spanien gibt es seit den letzten Monaten eine Anhäufung an Kreuzbandrissen, was wirklich unglaublich ist. Real Madrid hat es ja dann ziemlich stark erwischt. Im letzten Jahr schon mit Alaba, Dani Carvajal, Militao jetzt zum zweiten Mal. Bei Real Madrid brechen da gerade richtig viele Spieler weg. Da wird gerade heiß diskutiert, übrigens, wer da kommen soll, vielleicht jetzt im Winter. Emmerich Laporte vielleicht, zurück aus Saudi-Arabien. Oder Jonathan Tarr wurde sogar erwähnt. Sergio Ramos macht sich warm die ganze Zeit.
Wie sieht das aus, wenn Sergio Ramos sich warm macht? Geht er dann an den Boxsack?
Ungefähr. Er postet ständig Videos von sich selbst, wie er aus seiner Finca dort in Sevilla die Berge hoch und runter läuft. Durch seinen Pferdestall chockt er und, kurioserweise, wenn ich das richtig mitbekomme, hat er auch in der Halbzeitpause, nachdem Militao sich verletzt hat, auf seinen Social Media-Kanal gestellt, wie er gerade wieder trainiert. Also er möchte, glaube ich, sehr gerne wieder zu Real Madrid. Und er zeigt uns jede Woche einige Male, wie er fleißig trainiert und weiterhin sich fit hält, obwohl er ja schon auch 38 ist. Aber who knows? Nein, aber es ist einfach ein Fakt, finde ich, dass die Verletzungsanfälligkeit enorm gestiegen ist, was natürlich dem Spielplan zuzurechnen ist, der schwierig ist. Wir sehen es gerade jetzt auch wieder in dieser Nations League-Länderspielpause, wie viele Spieler auch absagen müssen, wie viele auch freiwillig absagen, weil sie einfach auch mal eine Woche frei brauchen zwischendurch. Ja, und ich finde es einfach echt sehr bemerkenswert, dass es so viele Kreuzband-Risse im Moment gibt. Es gibt wahrscheinlich nur zwei Lösungen. Entweder man beschränkt den Spielplan wieder, was nicht passieren wird, oder wir laufen darauf hinaus, dass wir irgendwann Megakader bekommen von 30 Leuten oder so weiter, wo du dann wirklich für jeden Wettbewerb eine andere Elf auf den Platz stellst. Also es nimmt keine gute Richtung, glaube ich, im Moment. Und man müsste sich da wirklich mal an den Tisch setzen und schauen, ob man da irgendwie eine Lösung findet. Denn ich denke, wenn es so weitergeht, gibt es wie gesagt nur die zwei Lösungen. Und die erste ist ja wahrscheinlich nicht gewollt. Und von daher werden wir mal sehen, was da noch in Zukunft passiert. Aber es wird mit Sicherheit nicht abnehmen, die Welle der großen Verletzungen.
Fabian, ganz kurz dazu eben, ist nicht nur in Spanien so, in Italien auch, wenn man die Kreuzbeine der Herren nimmt. Bremer hatte ich vorhin schon angerissen. Zapata von Torino, der in herausragender Form war, komplette Saison. Der Scamacca, der italienische Nationalstürmer, den es im Sommer erwischt hat. Das sind jetzt nur große Namen. Es sind andere auch noch dazugekommen. Also es ist wirklich auch in Italien eine starke Anstieg, speziell eben bei diesen Kreuzbandverletzungen.
Schauen wir mal, ob sich da irgendwas verändert. Also bei den Frauen hast du das schon seit vielen Jahren, dass da die Kreuzbände reisen. Also 3 an einem Wochenende ist im Frauenfußball europäisch gesehen gar nicht viel, muss man leider so sagen. Da ist es immer allen egal. Die Belastung wird immer höher. Aber so tolle Menschen wie Gianni Infantino sagen ja hier, ihr müsst jetzt mal auch bei uns an die Tür klopfen und energischer auftreten. Sind wir mal gespannt, wie sich das Ganze mit der Spielbelastung entwickelt und ob das andere Folgen hat als im Frauenfußball. Das muss man hier vielleicht dann doch noch mal einschränkender zu sagen. Aber Christian, nachdem du jetzt auch gerade ja eh schon das Wort hattest, dass du jetzt hier diese Runde beschließen und wir blicken mal wieder, endlich mal wieder auf die Rummer.
Ja, bevor ich auf die Rummer blicke, darf ich noch ganz kurz– ich hatte es vorhin vergessen, das wollte ich noch unbedingt unterbringen– es gibt eine Statistik zu Buongiorno, die finde ich unbedingt noch Platz nehmen sollte. Er hat von Februar dieses Jahres bis Oktober, klar da war die Sommerpause dazwischen, aber es sind halt doch einige Monate, kein einziges sozusagen Duell verloren, wenn ein Stürmer ihn ins Dribbling gegen ihn gegangen ist. Also er hat quasi kein einziges von Februar bis Oktober hat ihn ein gegnerischer Stürmer oder gegnerischer Spieler im Dribbling sozusagen geschlagen. Das nur sozusagen nochmal zu Bon Jovi. Genau. Also das finde ich echt beeindruckend.
Dritter Bündchenverweis von Alexi. Sehr gut. Was hat Claudio Ranieri mit Massimo Alegri gemeinsam?
Genau. Dann schauen wir jetzt nach Rom. Ja, die Rom hat einen neuen Trainer. Muss man ja auch immer wieder mal. Ja, es ist fix. Das Schönste an der Geschichte, fange ich damit an. Der neue Roma-Trainer, der ein Urrömer ist, der in Rom lebt, musste nach London fliegen, um dort den Vertrag zu unterschreiben, weil die Fritkens, die Eigentümer, dort sozusagen ihre Suche vorangetrieben haben. Und ist dann gestern Abend auf dem Flughafen in Rom sehr herzlich empfangen worden. Also das sagt schon alles darüber aus, würde ich sagen, dass der Urrömer Ranieri nach London musste, um die Roma wieder übernehmen zu dürfen, weil sie darum gebattelt haben. Ja, das Kapitel Juric, das jetzt im Nachgang, kann man sagen, logisch ein einziges Missverständnis war, ist eben zu Ende gegangen am vergangenen Wochenende. Zwei zu drei Niederlagen, Bologna, da war auch klar, für mich war klar. Ich habe gesehen, zweite Hälfte stand es dann eins drei, da war mir klar, der wird den Tag sportlich nicht überleben und so war es dann auch. Ja, und dann gab es eine lange Suche, wurden viele Namen gehandelt und am Ende wurde Sir Claudio Ranieri aus dem Ruhestand zurückgeholt, denn eigentlich hatte er seine Karriere, seine lange verdiente Karriere beendet. Aber wie es bei der Roma manchmal so ist, hat die Roma wirklich ein großes Glück. Es gibt halt viele große Persönlichkeiten des Fußballs, die der Roma sehr tief verbunden sind und einer davon ist Ranieri. Ich bin mir sicher, bei jedem anderen Anruf– ich weiss nicht, ob er gar nicht drangegangen wäre, auf jeden Fall hätte er abgesagt– aber bei der Roma, weil es eine Herzensangelegenheit ist, hat er nicht abgesagt. Im Gegenteil, er hat gesagt, ich möchte helfen, den Karren aus dem Dreck zu bringen. Und man muss wiederum sagen, schauen wir uns mal an. Klar, keine Ahnung, wie das sportlich läuft. Ich glaube schon, dass er logisch die Aura, die Ausstrahlung hat, da einfach erst mal ein bisschen Ruhe in den Laden reinzubringen. Aber mit Blick wieder auf die Eigentümer, auf die Schwitkins, es ist wieder so ein Move à la de Rossi, wie damals im Winter. Du besänftigst damit im Prinzip die Fans, denn das war wirklich ein Riesenproblem in den letzten Monaten, die haben sich hier unfassbar entfernt von der Roma und das war ja eigentlich das große Glück, das ist die große Stärke der Roma in den letzten Jahren. Also diese unfassbare Verbundenheit zwischen Roma, Tifosi und dem Club. Und die haben ja teilweise die Spiele boykottiert, diese Courvasutte ist teilweise immer später erst zu den Spielen rein. Gab wirklich in jedem Spiel, gab ja auch Pfeffer gegen Pellegrini, gegen Cristante, gegen dieses Symbolspieler. Und jetzt holst du halt einen, den jeder Roma-Fan liebt und dementsprechend besänftigst du jetzt halt erstmal wieder das Umfeld. Ja, wünsche ihm alles Gute. Ich glaube schon, dass Ranieri auch, wie gesagt, die menschlichen Qualitäten hat und auch die Fußballfachqualitäten mit dem Kader, mit dem man doch was anstellen kann, da halbwegs wieder in den Schwung zu bringen. Aber ja, mittelfristige, langfristige Lösung ist es logisch auch keine. Und dementsprechend wird sich dann halt die Frage stellen, welchen Plan diese Fritzkins haben. Also ich sage es jetzt noch mal ganz deutlich, es ist wirklich krass, finde ich, bitter, wie diese Eigentümer, die Roma, die eigentlich bis vor ein paar Monaten gut aufgestellt war, auf einem guten Weg war, dass sie in den letzten paar Monaten wirklich stark eingerissen hat, das Ganze. Und ja, kann nur sagen, als Neutraler, hoffentlich kommt die Roma wieder auf die Füße, weil das würde dem italienischen Fußball und allen, glaube ich, vielen, die den traditionellen Blick auf den Fußball haben, glaube ich, würde das freuen.
Also wir legen das ab unter das Glück, Investoren zu haben in seiner Liga und wir legen es ab. Ich meine, Claudio Ranieri mit 73 Jahren, also US-Präsident könnte er noch werden. Wer weiß, wie lange er…
Ich finde, dass du das Alter sagst. Genau, ich wollte dich auch noch ansprechen.
Ja, und wer weiß, vielleicht, also mich wundert es eigentlich, dass in dem Moment, in dem Iban Juric entlassen wurde, nicht Mats Hummels ein Video gepostet hat, wie er durch seinen Pferdestall joggt. Oder vielleicht habe ich da jetzt gerade was durcheinander geworfen. Aber vielleicht findet der ja auch wieder sein Plätzchen bei der Roma und das vielleicht ja sogar länger auf dem Feld, als es bisher zu sehen war. Ihr drei, das hat große Freude gemacht. Danke euch herzlich und wir machen an dieser Stelle jetzt dann noch einmal kurz weiter mit der Premier League. Uli Hebel ist jetzt hier und spricht mit mir über die Premier League. Uli, schön, dass du da bist.
Finde ich auch. Schönen guten Abend, grüß dich.
Ja, damit haben wir auch geleakt, dass ein halber Tag zwischen der Vormittagsaufnahme und jetzt liegt. Aber für dich ist es völlig egal. Den Hörern und Hörern ist das egal. Wir wollen sprechen über die Premier League. Und da wollen wir jetzt mal blicken auf Brighton. Denn das werden die Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen haben. Die stehen nicht nur fantastisch in der Tabelle da. Punktgleich mit Nottingham, Arsenal und Chelsea. Das ist quasi Platz 3, 4 und 5. Und Brighton dann eben auf 6 mit 19 Punkten. Sondern auch einen echten Überraschungssieg gelandet gegen City.
Ja, also Brighton erscheint auch nicht erweitert schon früh in der Saison. Also nicht erst jetzt im November oder auch im Oktober, sondern eigentlich mehr oder weniger von Spieltag 1 an hoch unterhaltsam. Damit habe ich einigermaßen gerechnet, dass es dem so sein könnte. Sie könnten hier und da etwas effizienter sein. Also Hürzeler selbst spricht da sehr deutlich davon, dass es naiv ist. Aber ich finde, in den allermeisten Spielphasen eigentlich wie ein richtiges Top-Team aufgestellt. Also spielen von hinten raus, haben wirklich einen sehr soliden Ballaufbau, sehr, sehr passsicher auch schon. Und das, obwohl im Übrigen ein paar fehlen, also es ist bei weitem noch nicht– sind alle gesund. Bloß die Mannschaft ist im Sommer sehr, sehr neu zusammengestellt worden. Also zum einen, weil de Zerbi gegangen ist, logisch, auf der anderen Seite, weil wie immer bei Brighton der ein oder andere gegangen ist und in dem Fall aber sogar, weil die Gewinne reinklicken, die sie gemacht haben in den letzten Jahren. Transfererlöse und so weiter und so weiter. Und aufgrund der– fällt das nochmal stärker ins Gewicht– aufgrund der Problematik, was PSA betrifft, also Nachhaltigkeitsregeln, die andere Vereine mitbringen, fällt es nochmal deutlich ins Gewicht, dass Brighton schon sehr, sehr viel Geld ausgegeben hat, vor allen Dingen offensiv Geld ausgegeben hat. Deswegen eigentlich alle damit gerechnet haben. Da kommt ein junger Trainer, der noch nie auf dem Niveau gecoacht hat, der noch nie natürlich in dem Land gecoacht hat, sogar in der Liga, in der es, sagt man immer, sehr kompliziert ist. Und dann noch mit neuen Spielern. Und dafür sieht es, finde ich, schon sehr, sehr flüssig aus, was passiert. Also sowohl am Ball als auch zum Teil gegen den Ball. Es gibt halt dann– und das ist aber dann vielleicht auch dem Alter geschuldet– schon immer mal so Phasen von 10 Minuten, wo sie dann wegknicken, dann wirklich auch teilweise Spiele nicht gewinnen, die sie eigentlich klar gewissen. Wolfs ist wahrscheinlich so ein Beispiel, das müsste gewesen sein Ende Oktober. Da laufen sie 4 gegen 1 auf einen Wolf zu und spielen den Ball tatsächlich in die Füße und kassieren halt dann den Ausgleich. Und da der sich halt maßlos drüber geärgert, Fabian nutzt auch zurecht auch, finde ich auch im Übrigen sehr cool, dass der dann nicht irgendwie einen Hehl daraus macht, dass er da enttäuscht ist und gar nicht in Schutz die Truppe nimmt, sondern im Gegenteil sagt er, ne, sorry, so können wir das nicht machen. Und das muss man gewinnen und fertig. Und das macht er im Übrigen in jedem Spiel. Und deswegen sind die schon zu nennen als die wahrscheinlich, also Nottingham, kommen wir dann vielleicht auch noch drauf, aber wahrscheinlich die größte Überraschung der Liga mit Nottingham zusammen.
Aber diese Ehrlichkeit, die du da angesprochen hast, und dass auch die Mannschaft dann in die Pflicht nehmen, kann das nicht auch backfiern, wie man auf Englisch sagt? Also, sich kontraproduktiv auswirken, wenn er das schon so früh macht in der Saison?
Ja, dessen ist er sich auch bewusst. Wer weiß schon, dass das Formulieren von Ambitionen, das ist jetzt ein sinngemäßes Zitat auch, das er ihm am Telefon gegeben hat, das Formulieren von Ambitionen kann natürlich auch als leichte Arroganz ausgelegt werden. Im Speziellen, wenn er es so vorträgt, wie er es vorträgt. Und im Moment, du weißt ja selber, manchmal ist es im Sportjournalismus auch um Narrative. Im Moment ist es Narrative in England, das ist das FAB, so nennen sie ihn schon, der junge Trainer, der dahin kommt, kein Respekt hat und dann sogar Guardiola weghaut, eine seiner Idole. Deswegen lässt man die andere Geschichte jetzt mal weg. Wenn es aber mal nicht so gut laufen würde, bin ich mir schon ziemlich sicher, und ich glaube, das weiß er auch, dann kommt es auch. Aber, und das ist das Gute an ihm, er ist sich dessen total bewusst. Also der geht da jetzt nicht blind rein und sagt, ja gut, jetzt findet er mich cool und später mögt er mich nicht so gerne, sondern ihm ist völlig klar, dass das ein Problem werden wird, so wie er sich aber nur mal ausdrücken möchte. Das ist das, das finde ich auch das Schöne. Das sage ich jetzt, das sagt nicht er, aber das ist für mich immer eine Metapher. Also ich will jetzt kein Name-Jopping betreiben oder so, aber es gibt ja zwei, drei deutschsprachige Trainer und in dem Fall lässt er sich darauf ein, dass ich ihn trotzdem anrufen darf, wenn ich ein Brighton-Spiel habe. Und er hat auch gesagt, es ist in Ordnung, das zu sagen. Und da habe ich mal mit ihm darüber geredet und nach dem Wolfs-Spiel, das ich kommentiert hatte, vor dem Liverpool-Spiel dann gesagt, ich will jetzt nicht irgendwie respektlos klingen oder so, aber wenn man jetzt das Ganze böse formulieren würde, dann wäre das naiv. Dann sagt er, ja, formulieren wir es doch böse, also ist es doch. Und das ist das, dann habe ich nur gesagt, oh, okay, dann sagt er, naja, nur wenn man jung ist, kann man trotzdem reif auftreten. Und das ist dann meine Anschätzung des Ganzen, das ist eine Metapher, die natürlich eine Doppelsinnigkeit hat. Weil ihn nervt das immer, glaube ich, mit dem Alter auf eine Weise, weil er sagt, nehmt mich bitte ernst als Fußballtrainer, was ich völlig verstehen kann, weil ich trainiere in der Premier League. Und ich werde, also du kriegst ja keinen extra Punkt, nur weil du 31 bist, was immer noch schon echt erstaunlich ist. Und ich glaube, das möchte er nicht. Er möchte diesen Schutz nicht, sondern er möchte als Fußballtrainer bewertet werden. Und er will ihn aber seinen Spielern auch nicht geben. Und das finde ich konsequent. Und ich glaube, das sind die Dinge, wo du als Fußballspieler wahrscheinlich sagst, hm, genau, der Trainer, der hat keine Doppelmoral, der fordert nicht für sich etwas ein, das er uns nicht gibt, sondern er macht so, wie es sich gehört. Ich glaube, das ist das, was hilft, wenn ich so die Truppe einschätze, gerade bei jungen Spielern. Es ist, glaube ich, extrem wichtig, dass der Trainer lebt, was er sagt.
Also auf den Kader und wer da die entscheidenden Spieler sind, müssen wir gleich noch mal kommen. Aber eine letzte Frage noch zu Hürzeler. Also es war natürlich ein großes Thema, dass er der erste Trainer ist, der jünger ist als die Liga, in der er trainiert mit seinen 31 Jahren. Ich weiß, dass viele englische Journalisten sich üben durften am Ort Pippinsried, der uns als Münchner natürlich leicht von den Lippen geht. Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger für die. Aber wie kommt er denn in der Medienöffentlichkeit an? Denn gerade als zum Beispiel Jürgen Klopp damals gewechselt ist in die Premier League, war das ja ein großes Thema. Wie würde er mit der Yellow Press und so weiter umgehen?
Also, wenn auch David das Narrativ sagt, das deutschsprachige Trainer, ich nehme jetzt mal Glas damit rein, wenn wir die Rückrunde bei Crystal Palace zählen, aber auch Hasenüttel zum Beispiel, Southampton, die haben schon gecheckt, dass es eine Fußballrichtung, also für die Engländer ist alles, was aus Deutschland kommt, Gegenpressing. Mehr gibt es nicht. Und das ist eine Fußballrichtung, die funktioniert. A, die B kopiert wird und die C von Deutschen gelehrt wird und deshalb war schon klar, die haben schon sehr, sehr viel Respekt gehabt, als er kam. Ich fand natürlich diesen Fakt des Wunderkids schon auch lustig, aber insgesamt mag man den medial sehr, weil– und das ist ja in England– gibt es ja keine Interviews links und rechts, gibt es ja überhaupt nicht. Also kein Journalist. Also geschweige denn die Kollegen aus England, mit denen ich korrespondiere, die fassen sich an den Schädel, wenn sie sagen, wieso telefonierst du mit dem Trainer? Und dann sag ich, was ist das los? Und dann sag ich, ist das irgendwie bei uns in Deutschland? Ist das so? Dass man halt irgendwie versucht, zumindest so vorm Spiel was zu machen. Und es gibt aber auch gar kein Print-Interview oder sowas. Weil die Print-Journalisten überhaupt gar nicht danach fragen. Das heißt, du siehst und triffst den bei Pressekonferenzen. Und ab und an mal, wenn der Beatwriter halt in der Mixed Zone stehen bleibt und der Trainer, wenn ihm langweilig ist, machen aber meistens die Co-Trainer. Und auch da versucht er halt einfach, kein riesiges Geheimnis aus der Sache zu machen. Das ist wahrscheinlich das Beste, was man über ihn sagen kann. Du fragst ihn was, er gibt dir eine Antwort. So gut er kann. Und das Gefühl habe ich und das Gefühl haben auch alle englischen Kollegen, dass er wirklich sagt, okay, wenn du es wissen willst, klar, erklär es dir. So gut ich halt kann.
Also sind wir mal gespannt, wie sich das alles weiterentwickeln wird. Es ist ja noch sehr früh in seiner Station jetzt bei Brighton. Jetzt hast du ja schon angesprochen, man hat auch sehr, sehr viel investiert, also über 200 Millionen Euro in neue Spieler gesteckt in diesem Sommer. Sind es denn auch die Neuzugänge, die diese Saison wesentlich prägen? Oder wer sind so die wichtigen Spieler?
Noch nicht so die Neuzugänge, würde ich sagen, weil bei Brighton, das ist aber, hat Methode, die transferieren eigentlich immer so, dass sie die Abgänge schon mal zwei Transferfenster im Voraus versuchen zu ersetzen. Das heißt, die kommen dann sozusagen nach einem Jahr oder vielleicht sogar eineinhalb Jahren erst so richtig in die Mannschaft rein, dürfen derweil mal heranschmecken. Das soll sich ändern. Brian Goddard zum Beispiel, der da ist, der soll, glaube ich schon, sehr, sehr schnell auch Richtung Stammmannschaft geführt werden. Wäre eine kleinere Ausnahme. Und Ruitier spielt sehr viel jetzt. Dessen Zahlen sind noch so la la, aber auch das weiß man bei Brighton oder wusste man. Der Besitzer, Tony Blum, ist ein Profi Pokerspieler. Und der ist ein sehr, sehr zahlenorientierter Fußballkonsument geworden. Also der ist einfach mal reingekommen als Fußballfan und hat sich das Ganze dann aber, weil er sehr zahlentalentiert ist, einfach mal alles zeigen lassen, sagen lassen. Und der muss irgendeinen Algorithmus entwickelt haben, der bei Ruitier geblinkt hat, sodass fast das Ding explodiert wäre, auf dem er den Algorithmus wahrscheinlich abgelesen hat. Und ich kann dir nicht genau sagen, welche Werte das sind. Darüber schweigt die gesamte Fußballwelt. Aber das war bei Hofmeister und so. Und es war auch bei Lidz so, dass genau das Gleiche passiert ist. Also ich vermute, das ist irgendwo im Bereich der Expected Assists, weil ich kann es mir nicht bei Expected Goals so richtig vorstellen. Der Abschluss ist Solala. Von dem irgendwie generell die Entscheidungsfindung ist Solala. Der ist sprachlich kommunikativ auch nicht so besonders. Das hat man mir auch in Hofmeyerm schon gesagt. Aber theoretisch ist das so ein 1 gegen 1 Monster, der so ganz clever die Zwischenräume besetzt. Und ich glaube, da könnte was gehen, wenn man denen sozusagen den Ball gibt, im Zwischenraum der dreht auf, läuft mit Tempo auf die Kette zu und würde dann das richtige Abspiel finden. Dann könnte der sehr gefährlich sein. Ich deute da immer mal an, dass der schwierig zu halten sein müsste, kommt aber kaum was rum. Und auch von den anderen, wenn ich mir das so überlege, eigentlich kein richtiger Neuzugang, der jetzt so eine totale Rolle spielt. Ich glaube, Matt O'Reilly, der jetzt am Wochenende gegen City dann das Tor geschossen hat, auch das Entscheidende. Das soll einer sein. Der war bis dato verletzt. Das soll derjenige sein, der sowohl die Standardsituation tritt, in Absenze von Groß und vor allen Dingen auch einfach Torgefahr aus dem Mittelfeld. Das haben sie nämlich so gar nicht. Ich glaube, der könnte eine Rolle spielen. Brian Guder ebenfalls, der auf dem rechten Flügel eingeplant ist. Aber ansonsten sind es eigentlich Mats Viva auch, der soll auch. Der ist aber viel verletzt. Danny Welbeck ist wahrscheinlich in dieser Saison, wenn ich einen nennen müsste, der, der den Unterschied am Ersten macht, liegt daran, dass er gesund ist. Das ist bei ihm zu allererst mal zu nennen. Weil ich glaube, wir würden völlig anders über Danny Welbeck sprechen, wenn er nicht dauernd verletzt gewesen wäre im Verlauf seiner Karriere. Das habe ich mir nur sagen lassen, er ist ein extremer Profi, hat einen eigenen Physiotherapeut, mit dem er wahnsinnig viel arbeitet, super fleißig, guckt viel, lässt sich viel sagen, will aber auch was haben von sich aus. Er ist immer so einer, der ist so leicht, im Englisch sagt man slick, also so gerissener Hund manchmal. Der lässt sich mal fallen, wo du denkst, was machst du da? Und dann zwei Sekunden später denkst du, ja, du öffnest den Raum damit, los geht's. Ich habe mir die Zahlen mal, das ist jetzt schon wieder eine Woche her, herausgeschrieben. Was seinen Abschlusspunkt angeht, ist er immer näher herangekommen im Verlauf seiner Karriere und ist jetzt da endlich mal komplett und nur auf der Neuen spielt, gar nicht mehr irgendwie Hengen-Spitze oder so etwas spielt, kommt immer näher ran bei seinen Abschlüssen. Entsprechend ist auch die Abschlussqualität gestiegen und aber auch die Verwertung gestiegen, weil er halt nur noch schießt oder abschließt, wenn er wirklich in einer aussichtsreicheren Position ist. Früher hat er manchmal geballert, kam einfach so von links rausgedriftet und hat einfach nur aus zweiter Reihe drauf geballert oder einfach mal irgendetwas genommen. Völlig wild und der wird immer cleverer. Ich glaube auch haushaltender, das zählt auch dazu, dass er sich das ein oder andere spart an Aktionen. Und deshalb in der Saison war wahrscheinlich der Main-Man, den Mitoma immer auch noch zu nennen, über den Flügel, weil der im 1 gegen 1, das ist eine Gravitation, die da ausstrahlt, den kannst du nicht alleine lassen, weil sonst spielt er dich einfach aus und dann hast du ein Problem, auch noch nicht so ganz effizient. Ich glaube, da geht noch was in dem Punkt. Aber von den Offensiven sind es die zwei in der Defensive, was wir wahrscheinlich Van Hecke nennen. Erstens, weil er von den Innenverteidigern der Einzige ist, der im Moment fit ist, permanent fit ist. Und zweitens, weil der gerade riesengroße Schritte macht, fußballerisch sowieso, richtig gut. Er kann undribbeln, ist ein sehr, sehr progressiver Verteidiger, sowohl im Dribbling als auch im Passen geworden. Das ist auch so einer. Der war da so eineinhalb Jahre im Kader und alle dachten so, ja, Van Hecke, was weiß ich. Und irgendwann, vor einem Jahr, so um die Zeit, kam er plötzlich und du denkst dir, oh, krass, ist Instant einer der besten jungen Innenverteidiger und hat jetzt inzwischen Level, dass der der Nächste ist, der für 60, 70 weggehen könnte, wenn sie loswerden wollen oder müssen irgendwann.
Ja, krasse Entwicklung bei Brighton. Und ich glaube, da müsste man auch nochmal im Detail mal draufgucken, was Danny Bloom da anders macht als vielleicht andere. Aber vorerst reicht das ja erst mal, um zu verstehen, warum Brighton so gut in die Saison gestartet ist und was eben auch die Talking Points sind. Neben The Fab, Fabian Hürzeler, der da quasi der Captain auf diesem Schiff ist, hast du uns noch jemand mitgebracht. Wir wollen noch ein paar kürzere Personalien und Geschichten abhandeln. Du hast für mich denjenigen mitgebracht, der bei Chelsea die Fäden in der Hand hält, den Überblick behält. Wie kann man es überhaupt formulieren? Wir wollen über Enzo Baresca sprechen.
Ganz so sicher bin ich mir auch noch nicht. Wer, wie, wo, was. Am Anfang der Saison habe ich immer gesagt, wir wissen ja leider viel zu viel von den ganzen Dingen, die da bei Clear Lake Capital zu stattfinden. Bei Maurizio Pochettino war es immer so, dass man gemerkt hat, dass er nicht hinter dem steht, was Clear Lake Capital ihm vorgibt, zu was er zu stehen hat. Und Enzo Baresca zu Beginn der Saison genau das gesagt, was die von ihm wollten. So hatte ich das Gefühl. Da tut man fast noch ein bisschen unrecht, weil man sagt, das ist deren Marionette, der macht das halt mal. Und sie wollten halt ein, zwei Spieler loswerden, wie zum Beispiel Remi Stirling, Ben Chilwell, alles Spieler. Das ist die Idee von Clear Lake Capital. Niemand, den wir nicht geholt haben, soll in diesem Verein sein. Weg. Sowohl im Staff als auch in der Mannschaft. Weg. Kostet es, was es wolle. Wirklich egal. Also kein Rücksicht auf das persönliche Schicksal eines Maseurs. Weg. Du bist kein Clear Lake Capital-Macher.
Es geht auch um den Staff, nicht nur ums Spiel. Ja, ja.
Alles. In diesem Verein hat niemand zu arbeiten, der nicht von Clear Lake Capital verpflichtet wurde.
Alter.
Immerhin konsequent und auch nach außen nicht so, aber nach innen wohl sehr, sehr deutlich kommuniziert. Zum Teil zu deutlich, so dass natürlich, kannst du dir vorstellen, das sind teilweise Legenden, Kid-Man und sowas. Naja.
Sieht ja wie die Busfahrer auf Schalke damals.
Genau. Ganz genau. Ja, das ist einfach der Verein. Da sind mir die Jesse-Fans immer so böse, wenn ich das sage. Aber der Verein, der jetzt geworden ist und der Clilic Capital, hat nichts mehr mit dem zu tun unter Braumowitsch. Und schon gar nicht mit dem, was vorher war. Gar nicht. Also überhaupt gar nicht. Das ist noch dasselbe Logo. That's it. Ansonsten nichts mehr. Ich finde es bewundernswert, wie Fans da dabei bleiben können, weil das wäre so der Moment, wo ich sagen würde, ja sorry, aber nur, weil es halt…
Ja gut, wahrscheinlich hilft halt Platz 3 mit 19 Punkten.
Ja, aber gut, genau. Da kommen wir dann ja zu dem positiven Punkt bei Enzo Maresca. Also die wollten die alle loswerden. Maresca hat gesagt, ja okay, wenn ihr denn loswerden wollt, ich sag nach außen, ich will ihn nicht, tschüss. Und der hat sich einfach aus diesem riesengroßen Kader, der es ja im Sommer gewesen ist, von theoretisch vier Mannschaftsbussen, dann gibt es natürlich eine Lone Army, der fährt schon mal ein Bus irgendwo hin, und dann hast du nur noch drei Busse und irgendwann waren es dann nur noch zwei, hat er einfach gesagt, okay, das sind meine vier bis 26 Jungs, mehr nicht, der Rest interessiert mich nicht, brauche ich nicht. Und das hat schon mal fürs Erste dafür gesorgt, dass, glaube ich, die Mannschaft gemerkt hat, oh, da ist Zug dahinter. Dann ein paar stringente Spiele, die da drin sind, das ist hoch unterhaltsam, was Chelsea tut, aber es ist in allererster Linie aufs Umschalten ausgelegt. Das heißt, sie spielen jetzt nicht den wunderschönsten Ball, was vielleicht auch mit Blick auf Leicester, was er da gemacht hat, gar nicht so schlecht ist, sich das so anzugucken. Und es hat sich einfach eine erste Mannschaft draus kristallisiert. Er hat einzelne Spieler, die Schwierigkeiten hatten, eine Zeit lang unter Pochettino, zum Schluss muss man fairerweise sagen, auch besser reingekommen sind. Also die Rückrunde war schon ganz ordentlich, hat sich die Qualität dann schon auch gezeigt, aber mit diesen verschiedenen individuellen Formen jeweils noch mal was angestellt, in die richtige Richtung gegossen, hat sich eine Stammmannschaft draus manövriert, was auch schon mal ganz wichtig war, weil es halt ein ewiges Gewechsel war die ganze Zeit und das dann noch mit so einer riesengroßen Kabine, das ist alles einfach wahnsinnig schwierig. Und er ist weiterhin sehr, sehr straight in dem, was er tut und vorgibt, sowohl eben außerhalb, bei den Antworten, die er so gibt, als auch auf dem Platz. Und das führt dazu, dass Chelsea's Qualität halt einfach– das war uns immer klar, das war ja auch deshalb das Projekt, vor dem die Fußballwelt, glaube ich, große Angst hat, weil wenn es funktioniert, dann weißt du ja selber, wie es ist, dann gibt es die Copycats. Und deswegen hat die ganze Fußballwelt so Angst davor, dass das funktioniert. Es war aber auch klar, die Qualität ist so überbordend gut, da steckt natürlich so viel an stilistischen Absichten drin, dass irgendwann mal irgendwas funktionieren müsste. Das sehen wir jetzt gerade. Und man muss aber insofern mal respektlos lassen, bis dato ist das nicht Elite. Soweit würde ich nicht gehen. Da fehlen mir schon noch ein paar Ansätze, dann auch gegen tiefere Gegner und so weiter. Aber sie haben insbesondere auch gegen Top-Teams gezeigt, da ist was da. Und auch mehr als nur ein formstarker Cole Palmer, der Darling von allen im Moment. Zu Recht auch, der spielt sensationell, das ist einfach ein wahnsinnig unterhaltsamer Spieler. Super Flair. Aber es ist schon mehr als das. Da steckt schon viel mehr drin. Das muss man Jersey lassen. Da haben sie einen Riesenschritt im Vergleich zu den letzten beiden Jahren gemacht, aber insbesondere auch noch mal zur letzten Saison. Deshalb Enzo Maresca, glaube ich, wäre fairerweise ein richtiger MVP, also wirklich valuable für Jersey.
Und wenn wir bei Menschen sind, die gegen Top-Teams da sind, dann können wir auch sehr gut zu Alexander Isak überleiten von Newcastle, denn der war unter anderem im Heimspiel gegen Arsenal da. 1 zu 0 Sieg. Er hat das Tor erzielt. Er war dann auch beim Auspelssieg bei Nottingham Forest da. 3 zu 1. Auch dort ein Tor, eine Vorlage. Der hat gerade eine sehr gute Phase.
Ja, ich sag es irgendwie, finde ich so ein neues Profil, das es gibt. Eigentlich ein Winger, so was die, was so die, die, also Lang, Dürr, aber ist nie ein Neuner geworden, sondern hat so was Wingerisches. So wie Ikke Tikee finde ich auch. So habe ich das auch in einem Bundesligaspiel mal gesagt. Ist auch so einer Leao irgendwie auf eine Weise. Das sind so Typen, die, wenn du die anschaust, würdest du denken, sie machen andere Dinge, als sie letztlich tun. Aber sie sind irgendwie immer ein bisschen drahtig geblieben und deswegen so schwer zu verteidigen. Und bei Isaac ist es auch so ähnlich wie, wie bei, bei so vielen, in Dortmund hat man ja schon gesehen, worum es gehen könnte. Dann bei der Altsocietat erst recht, aber nie gesund geblieben. Das war immer das große Problem bei dem. Auch bei Newcastle am Anfang, nie gesund geblieben. Trotzdem, je länger er dabei war, je länger er gesund war, desto besser ist er geblieben sozusagen. Und inzwischen ist das eigentlich alles, was du willst. Ist ein, der hat eine dermaßen starke Technik, kannst du dir gar nicht vorstellen. Der hat Läufe abseits des Balles, die natürlich auch noch durch die Athletik verstärkt werden. Super clevere Bewegungen. Läuft ständig in die Tiefe, kann aber genauso gut mit Ball am Fuß richtig eintribbeln, also richtig öffnen sozusagen. Hat für einen Stürmer eine wahnsinnig gute Balance. Ist de facto beidfüßig, wenn du so willst. Also ein bisschen schwierig, das sagen auch immer alle Scouts, das gibt es nicht. Und ich weiß auch, was sie meinen, so richtig gibt es das natürlich nicht. Aber wenn ich es dir jetzt vorher nicht sagen würde, dann würdest du wahrscheinlich draufkommen und sagen, der hat eigentlich einen relativ sauberen Schuss und eine relativ saubere Technik mit beiden Füßen. Ein guter Tripler und so etwas wie so ein Ein-Mann-Offensive, der eigentlich permanent Newcastle selber mal mit irgendwas, also sowohl wenn das Spiel mal steht, als auch im Transit, kann alles und wenn er gesund ist, Wahnsinn.
Unglaublich, wie der sich entwickelt hat. Ich meine, man hat es ja schon bei Réa Sociedad gesehen und deswegen ist er ja auch für viel Geld in die Premier League gewechselt. Aber ja, eins von vielen Dortmunder Talenten, das sich dann später nochmal richtig entwickelt hat. Das wäre…
Und nie eine Chance da bekommen hat, wenn wir ganz ehrlich sind. Also oder zumindest wahrscheinlich zu einem Zeitpunkt, als es noch unfair war, den richtig zu bewerten, weil das war mir aber auch relativ früh klar.
Das ist ein Fehler.
Der Körper alleine, da steckt viel drin.
Ja, gut. Ich meine, er hatte natürlich immer diese Größe und eben gleichzeitig diese Schlagsigkeit. Deswegen hat man vielleicht auch zu sehr klassische Mittelstürmer-Dinge von ihm erwartet. Auf der anderen Seite, der BVB hat es ja schon versucht, so zu machen, wie man es dann eben mit einem solchen Talent tun sollte. Nämlich, du verleihst ihn erstmal und guckst, ob er sich entwickelt. Und dann schaust du drauf. Und vielleicht haben sie dann zu früh dann aus welchen Gründen auch immer entschieden, okay, wir verkaufen ihn.
Da kann man auch mit 17. Der ist ja immer noch super jung. Das darf man immer noch nicht vergessen.
Genau.
Eigentlich geht es erst los. Also schon. Aber Theo Wolkert, glaube ich, hat das gesagt. Ich hoffe, ich mixe es jetzt nicht. Ich glaube, BBC, dass das Our Generation's Thierry Oury ist, was dann schon auch viel sagt. Passt nicht so ganz von der Spielweise, finde ich. Ist sogar einen Ticken kompletter, so blöd, das klingen mag, als Oury. Aber das ist, glaube ich, halt einfach so, weil sich die Spielerprofile generell zu komplett entwickelt haben. Oury wäre heute, glaube ich, auch jemand anderes, als er damals gewesen ist. Aber ich weiß, dass man meint, jemand, der für Newcastle halt ganz oft das Spiel packt und zack.
Tja. Ja, gut. Und wenn jemand weiß, wie es ist, sich in jungen Jahren mit großen Erwartungen auseinanderzusetzen, dann ja die U-War-Court. Das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema. Und unser letztes Thema haben wir schon kurz gestreift, nämlich Nottingham Forest. Auch wenn man verloren hat, eben gegen Newcastle, steht man sehr, sehr gut da. Man ist eben auch bei den Teams mit dabei, die 19 Punkte haben und damit von Rang 3 bis Rang 6 liegen, so wie Brighton, über die wir schon gesprochen haben. Was macht denn da Nottingham Forest gerade richtig?
Also zuallererst, das klingt immer so blöd, weil ja klar, aber sie haben eine klare Identität. Das hatten sie nie, seitdem sie zurück sind in der Premier League. Und wenn dann, unter Steve Cooper, dann war es halt Defensive First, aber das war es dann auch. Also du hast da vorne keinerlei Ideen gehabt. Das kommt jetzt dazu. Auch da die gleiche Erzählweise wie bei Chelsea. 140.000 Menschen verpflichtet seit dem Wiederaufstieg. Aber am Ende spielt trotzdem immer Ryan Yates. Also gerade fürs zentrale Mittelfeld. An dem kann man so festmachen, was die alles verpflichtet haben in der Zeit. Brazillianer haben ohne Ende Südamerikaner mit drin. Mongola, also you name it. Und dann spielt am Ende wieder Ryan Yates. Und das ist jetzt zum einen so, dass sie das machen. Ich finde, dass sie relativ clever manchmal vorne draufgehen. Wenn das nicht funktioniert, dann ziehen sie sich wieder zurück. Mir ist das noch zu passiv, deswegen glaube ich, dass ich das nivellieren würde. Aber bis dato funktioniert das einigermaßen. Und wenn sie den Ball selbst haben, dann ist das weiterhin sehr umschaltbasiert. Sie spielen direkt, haben eine relativ gute Pace-Abballeroberung, so Diagonalbälle und so weiter, die Dinge brechen. Dann hast du jemanden drin wie Morgan Gibson White, der ist wahrscheinlich so ein All-Action-Achter, wenn du so willst. Der ist super schwierig zu verteidigen. Das hat in der Zeit lang die ganze Liga gecheckt. Aber dann gehen halt auf der anderen Seite in Ilanga, Ramon Sosa, ganz egal, wie man dann nennen will. Die haben viel Qualität. Dann auch auf den Halbzehner-Position oder Flügelposition. Das ist immer so ein Mischmasch bei denen. Und dann haben sie Chris Wood, der einfach mal wieder– der kann nichts. Es tut mir total leid, wenn ich das so sage. Ich kann nichts. Ich kann einfach nicht Fußball spielen. Aber der erste Kontakt– das ist ein Finisher, das hast du nicht gesehen. Der Kopfball, die Chancenverwertung ist der Wahnsinn. Der zieht leicht nach links, kriegt einen Ball, drin ist er. Teamdienlich, es scheint ein super, super guter Typ zu sein, aber eigentlich kann er nichts. Sobald der einen zweiten Kontakt haben müsste, dann sind seine Mannschaftskollegen am Ende, weil dann ist der Ball weg. Aber sie kriegen ihn halt in solche Möglichkeiten. Das kommt wie immer, wenn so ein Team da oben steht, ist eine gewisse Effizienz erforderlich. Die ist da alleine aufgrund von Chris Wood eben. Nuno Spiritu Santo hat noch nie mehr immer nachgesagt, dass das jemand ist, der eher dann scheint, einen guten Analysten zu haben. In der zweiten Hälfte dann ein paar Dinge umbaut und dann in der zweiten Hälfte dem Gegner ganz gut noch mal zersetzt, also in-game-management, aber eher in halftime-management in dem Fall. Aber auch das funktioniert jetzt von vorneherein etwas besser bei denen und auch das ist, kann man schon sagen, glaube ich, insgesamt eine ziemlich körperliche Mannschaft. Wenngleich, und das habe ich schon gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass die dahin gehören, wo sie sind im Moment, weil mir das wesentlich zu passiv ist insgesamt, weil mir das Pressing nicht gut genug aufgestellt ist und weil, und das ist einfach das, was so ins Auge fällt, weil im Moment jeder Einzelne dermaßen drüber ist, was die Form betrifft. Also es ist unmöglich, dass sie es halten können. Jeder Einzelne ist ein Absoluter, die brennen allesamt. Und das kann so nicht weitergehen. Bis jetzt immer noch das einzige Thema, auch das Liverpool geschlagen hat in der gesamten Spielzeit. Es war genauso eine Masterclass, wie sie es eigentlich immer gemacht haben. Sie stellen sich hinten hin, Robo-Dope, der Gegner soll kommen, kann aber nicht durch. Und irgendwann hast du halt einen Moment und der ist halt dann drin.
Klar.
War wirklich nur einer, der war drin.
Gibt Chris Wood nur einen Kontakt und dann läuft es gut.
Genau.
Ja, sehr schön. Und dann haben wir nämlich auch indirekt. Wir haben ja das letzte Mal mit Jogi hier Ende Oktober über United gesprochen. Und da haben wir die Perspektive von United dann nicht mehr so wirklich noch angeschnitten, weil wir schon so lange gesprochen hatten. Aber warum es United auch mit neuem Trainer wahrscheinlich schwer haben wird, liegt, glaube ich, an allen Teams, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben. Ja, das ist schon eine spannende Situation.
Da sind sie schon auch selber schuld. So ist es nicht. Aber immerhin, ich wäre mir echt viel geschimpft in der letzten Dekade über Man United und auch zurecht. Und auch da werden Menschen links und rechts entlassen, die da seit Jahren Leistung bringen im Verein. Ich meine jetzt noch nicht mal die Mannschaft, sondern im Verein. Aber, und das habe ich mir nochmal sagen lassen, mit sehr viel mehr Klasse. Also es wird nicht einfach wahllos ausgedünnt, du weg, du weg, du weg, du weg, sondern es wird geguckt. Wie geht es den Familiär? Kann es das irgendwie, irgendwas, können wir den vielleicht irgendwo anders noch einen Job geben? Es ist ein insgesamt sehr langsamer Verein, was auch jetzt so die Kulturveränderung betrifft, was glaube ich dann positiv ist. Trotzdem natürlich ist es, wie es ist. Ineos ist da und die wollen Erfolg haben und zwar auch einigermaßen schnell Erfolg haben, aber es ist nicht haruk. Also, man könnte das auch wie bei Chelsea machen und sagen, so, du bist jetzt hier 20 Jahre Kidman. Ja, whatever, ciao. Das macht man halt so nicht. Und nicht nur deshalb, aber auch deshalb. Ich habe das Gefühl, Ineos, also ich habe mir ein bisschen was erzählen lassen aus dem Trainerfindungsprozess. Scheint ein sehr, sehr, sehr langfristiger gewesen zu sein. Sehr, sehr viele Background-Checks, also auch da viel im Datenbereich, viel aber auch grundsätzlich, was die Machbarkeit betrifft. Also gar nicht bei Guardiola angefragt oder so wie halt Bayern. Jeden einzelnen Trainer, der eine UEFA-POL-Lizenz hat, der fragt man mal vorsichtig an mit so einem Brief oder was Böse formuliert. Sondern schon nach Machbarkeit und auch wahnsinnig viel privater Background-Check. Also im Sinne von ist die Persönlichkeit für uns ausreichend, damit da nicht wieder jemand kommt, dem es einfach über den Kopf wächst. Und ich habe insgesamt so das Gefühl, dass INEOS einen ganz guten Plan hat. Haben auf allen erdenklichen Positionen Leute installiert. Also endlich mal so was wie einen Director of Sports, einen technischen Direktor, beides sogar. Hatten sie ja ewig nicht. Einfach eine fußballerische Leitlinie. Geschweige denn den Plan, das ist da. Deswegen auf dem Weg in die richtige Richtung. Aber ja, das ist ja das Bittere. Während United jetzt zum nächsten Mal neu aufbaut, haben sich halt in der Zwischenzeit schon wieder 3, 4, 5 Teams komplett neu erfunden und sind schon wieder vorbeigezogen. Das ist das Gestaunliche.
Aber wirklich.
Lange Antwort, sorry.
Du, alles gut. Jetzt haben wir noch spontan über United gesprochen. Ist doch schön. Uli, ich danke dir sehr, sehr herzlich für deine Zeit. Das hat wie immer große Freude gemacht.
Danke dir.
Und ich danke natürlich auch nochmal unseren Gästen von vor Jahren, Fabian Pakulat, Christian Bernhardt und Alexi Menüsch. Und zuletzt möchte ich natürlich auch euch danken, lieben Hörern und Hörern. Denn ihr ermöglicht Sendungen wie diese hier. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werber und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Und unter anderem haben das getan Grumbas, Dumbas, Knupsch, der Seebe, Killer, FFM, Casper und Samira. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de gegangen und haben dann auf den Unterstützen-Button geklickt. Den findet ihr sehr einfach. Und da erfahrt ihr auch, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Geht eigentlich auf allen gängigen Wegen. Jeder Betrag hilft. Herzlichen Dank für euren Support. Herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt gesund und uns gewogen. Und dann hören wir uns bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut, ciao! Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!